nous passons à l'article liminaire avec
un amendement de suppression de
l'article liminaire et je passe la
parole à Monsieur Guedj
s'il vous plaît bonjour madame la
Présidente chers collègues je vais
parler fort
alors c'est sur l'article liminaire qui
est vous le savez une disposition prévue
par la loi organique où elle FSS la loi
organique Meynier c'est-à-dire
l'occasion pour moi de saluer notre
ancien collègue Thomas mignon partagé
pas les mêmes idées mais c'était un élu
qui comptait dans la commission des
affaires sociales et j'en profite pour
saluer l'élection de René Pilato dans
cette dans cette circonscription voilà
alors la loi organique la loi organique
Meynier elle prévoit justement
d'actualiser les sols des
administrations publiques pour pouvoir
avoir cette visibilité et vous voyez
avec cet amendement de suppression qui
permet de dire toute l'opposition que
nous avons à cette réforme puisque en
effet elle a des impacts ne serait-ce
que le début de l'allongement de trois
mois à partir de septembre 2023 des
durées de cotisation et l'impact
financier mais permettez-moi de vous
dire madame la Présidente en
prolongement de ce que vous a dit Arthur
de la porte en réponse à votre propos
liminaire quand vous nous dites que il y
a un problème de recevabilité en
fonction de la date d'impact ça pointe
comme nous le faisons d'ailleurs avec
cette amendement laberration qu'a
constitué le recours à un PLFSS
rectificatif pour réformer sur les 50 ou
60 prochaines années notre système de
retraite parce que ce que vous nous avez
dit madame la Présidente c'était un
vibrant plaidoyer sur le côté monstrueux
juridiquement du recours à un PLFSS en
nous disant je ne peux prendre recevable
que ceux qui ont un impact sur 2023
alors que précédemment le gouvernement
réforme sur la durée de deux ou trois
générations et nous aurions aimé en
effet que ça ne passe pas crème qui est
pas cette espèce de résignation absolue
qui a consiste à dire ah bah c'est
absolument normal on réforme les
retraites par cet outil juridique dont
un ancien président de la commission des
lois a dit ce matin qu'il était
autoritaire et nous commission de la
classe sociale on se soumette à cela cet
article de suppression de l'article il
porte aussi le rejet de cette
monstruosité juridique très bien
amendement suivant défendu par Monsieur
Fabrice brun monsieur Boni ou monsieur
Baker pas défendu très bien monsieur
Petavy pour l'amendement suivant
l'article liminaire établit les soldes
structurel et le sol défectif de
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
l'ensemble de ces prévisions
correspondent à celles qui figurent dans
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour les années 2023 2027 ce
texte prévoyait dans les articles 17 à
20 de cantonais les dépenses des robes
et du Fonds de solidarité vieillesse à
21,8% du PIB de 2023 jusqu'à 2025
l'augmentation du PIB provoquera
mécaniquement une augmentation en volume
des dépenses de santé toutefois cette
augmentation ne sera que factice et ne
répondra pas à des investissements
supplémentaires puisque rapportés au
Pays Basque il n'y a aucune progression
cet article est ainsi son miroir en PLFR
SS et le groupe écologiste est en
favorable à une dynamique
d'investissement dans le système de
protection sociale et opposé à une
logique d'austérité le présent
amendement invocation à supprimer cet
article
très bien amendement suivant madame
Rousseau
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
monde vise à supprimer l'article dont il
est question et pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'on commence le débat en
parlant valeur travail et juste après on
entre dans le débat par les questions
financières et en fait là il s'agit
encore une fois d'un projet de société
d'un choix de vie de leur partage entre
travail et non travail et en fait et
tout à fait le temps libre et libéré et
oui et que c'est pas c'est pas honteux
non plus d'en bénéficier ça fait même ça
porte un nom ça s'appelle le progrès
social et le progrès humain et donc
entrer dans cette loi par la question
des finances dit bien à quel point on
tord la vie des gens et on met en danger
leur santé et y compris leur santé
physique et morale uniquement au prisme
des finances publiques nous sommes pour
la suppression de cet article
très bien la parole est à Madame panot
merci madame la Présidente alors on
avait hâte de commencer l'examen de
cette réforme
en commission des affaires sociales
parce que plus vous parlez plus le
nombre de Français qui sont contre cette
réforme augmente plus vous parlez plus
les gens comprennent que ce sont
effectivement les femmes qui vont être
pénalisés c'est d'ailleurs le ministre
Yester qui le dit plus vous faites de la
pédagogie deux semaines de pédagogie du
gouvernement c'est plus 13 points de
français et de françaises qui sont
contre cette réforme et surtout plus
vous parlez plus les Français se rendent
compte à quel point vous êtes déconnecté
ça va évidemment des exosquelettes qui
expliqueraient que la pénibilité
n'existe pas jusqu'à les genouillères
pour les carreleurs qu'il a aussi
expliquent qu'il n'y aurait pas besoin
de pénibilité supplémentaire jusqu'à
cette sortie magnifique en commission
des finances ou on nous explique que les
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap payer 760 euros par mois en
moyenne on choisit ce métier pour avoir
leur mercredi et leurs vacances
scolaires et pouvoir s'occuper de leur
propre enfant donc on était au summum du
mépris qu'on a hâte d'écouter vos
arguments dans cette commission des
affaires sociales et s'il y a un point
sur lequel les Français les françaises
ne vous croient pas c'est bien celle du
fait qu'il y ait une nécessité
économique à faire cette réforme alors
vous connaissez par cœur ce que dit le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites qui
a été redit notamment par le président
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
qui étaient auditionnées par la
commission des finances il dit les
dépenses de retraite ne dérapent pas
elles sont relativement méprisées dans
la plupart des hypothèses elle diminue
plutôt à terme donc personne ne vous
croit et d'ailleurs si on regarde les 12
milliards dont est en train de se
targuer le gouvernement pour expliquer
qu'il devrait faire cette cette réforme
et bien ce n'est rien sur les 346
milliards que constitue le retraite et
d'ailleurs s'il y a un trou c'est bien
parce que vous l'avez créé notamment
j'ai demandé plusieurs fois combien
avait coûté les primes Macron aux
caisses d'assurance vieillesse et je
voudrais terminer
en demandant à Madame la rapporteur si
il est vrai ce que dit le collectif de
nos services publics qui dit que dans
les prévisions de déficit de retraite le
gouvernement tape sur un appelle des
effectifs et une baisse réelle de
rémunération de 11% 2027
oui madame la Présidente la semaine
dernière on recevait les syndicats et la
CGC le syndicat des cadres et venir
apporter les données de la Banque de
France qui disait que la part revenons
aux salariés a baissé significativement
de 59 à 54% moins 5 points pendant que
la part aux actionnaires à triplé
passant de 5 à 15% lors des 20 dernières
années et ininterroger en disant mais
finalement ce partage de la valeur
ajoutée il y a rien dans votre projet
pour le changer et vous faites rien pour
le changer il vous interrogez pour qui
vous menez cette politique au service de
qui êtes-vous est-ce que vous êtes au
service salarié de français ou des fonds
de pension anglo-saxon alors là il y a
Sylvain Maillard député la majorité qui
s'est retourné choqué en disant mais
comment vous permettez d'insinuer que on
serait pas au service de tous les
Français et il nous prenait à témoin
comme si nous on allait le défendre
contre les syndicats mais non ce
monsieur des cadres a dit exactement ce
que nous pensions c'est que vous au
service de la finance plutôt que de la
France c'est que vous êtes au service
aujourd'hui avec ce projet très
clairement des fonds de pension plutôt
que des salariés français pourquoi parce
que là on a on va nous donner des
apparences faussement budgétaires
techniques pendant le même temps on
supprime sur la contribue la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises et en particulier des
grandes entreprises qui va coûter 8
milliards d'euros à l'État français ça
vous pose pas de souci ce qui est en jeu
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui le dit ce qui
est en jeu c'est l'autorité de votre
serviteur on va donner des apparences
techniques aujourd'hui à cette
discussion budgétaire financière avec
des chiffres et ainsi de suite mais la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
la pure politique c'est-à-dire dans un
enjeu de pouvoir quand on fait ça contre
tous les syndicats de France compte sur
cette Français sur 10 contre 8 salariés
sur 10 même contre des patrons vous vous
radicalisez vous vous radicalisez vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans un extrémisme pour
imposer cette réforme contre un corps
social qui n'en veut pas que vous
brutalisez la France aujourd'hui elle
aurait besoin de douceur elle aurait
besoin de tend après trois ans de crise
covid après la guerre en Ukraine la
crise de l'inflation et vous vous BR
brutalisez le corps social la parole est
à Monsieur Daredevil
ah pardon
oui madame Garin pardon
monsieur
à tous et à tous chers collègues je
crois que cet article similaire illustre
bien votre politique d'austérité que
vous voulez mettre en place et en plus
vous essayez de faire peur aux Français
avec ça quand bien même on l'a déjà
évoqué je crois qu'on va le rappeler
beaucoup pendant ces débats le corps
nous dit que le système n'est pas un
faillite et comme ça ça n'imprime pas
finalement cet argument d'un coup vous
nous mettez un peu de maquillage et vous
nous parlez de justice sociale quand
bien même on voit que cette réforme elle
touche en premier les femmes et elle va
les affecter durablement et finalement
ça nous montre que vous êtes bien
souvent incapable de penser une
politique publique en pensant au plus
vulnérable en premier ces arguments
d'austérité ils peuvent pas justifier un
passage en force notamment quand on sait
que la majorité des Français et des
Français sont opposés à cette réforme
des retraites et on le constate aussi
avec finalement la réforme que nous
avait fait pour l'assurance chômage
c'est qu'à chaque fois vous refusez de
re questionner la place du travail dans
notre société et dans et de mettre en
route une réforme d'ampleur donc ça veut
dire oui effectivement questionner notre
temps de travail ça veut dire
questionner ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui je travaille pour la
jeunesse et ça veut dire aussi penser
une retraite qui soit juste pour tous et
toutes alors ou notamment les conditions
climatiques vont rendre certaines
conditions de travail de plus en plus
difficiles et tout ça vous ne le prenez
pas en compte dans votre iPhone
merci bien Madame la Députée monsieur
d'arriville à la parole cette fois-ci
merci madame la Présidente
chacun de nos amendements porte une
exigence celle du retrait de ce texte et
je voudrais pas que vous pensiez que
parce que l'examen en commission a
commencé cette revendication serait
derrière nous elle continue de
s'exprimer dans le pays et nous allons
continuer de la porter ici alors cet
article liminaire finalement s'étonne un
peu que vous reveniez avec un texte de
cette nature avec effectivement toutes
les formes qui sont qui lui sont liées
avec cette article qui un tableau qui
est un tableau budgétaire puisque un
PLFSS a été adopté il y a une poignée de
semaine
avec nous croyons des dégâts qui vont
être fait à la fois sur le volet
sanitaire mais évidemment avec la
réforme que vous mettez sur la table
pour notre droit à la retraite
très bien
la parole
c'est moi qui vais l'apprendre si vous
voulez bien Madame la Présidente je
regrette bien que notre requête
d'examiner l'article 7 en priorité n'est
pas été retenu parce qu'au vu du début
des débats je vous cache pas mon
inquiétude je crains qu'entre le cas de
contraints auquel nous sommes
soumis par le gouvernement et
l'embolisation législative voulue par
elle et fiches j'ai bien peur que les
Français soient les grands oubliés de
ces débats cet amendement vise à
supprimer l'article liminaire permettant
de donner des gages au marché financier
cette dérive est préjudiciaire vous
assurer socio c'est pourquoi nous allons
le refuser nous refusons la présence de
ces indices financiers en tête de ce
texte qui décide de la répartition de
l'effort de solidarité dans notre pays
cet article liminaire expose les
perspectives de recettes et de dépenses
des administrations des amis j'ai perdu
mon truc de sécurité sociale qui repose
sur des prévisions économiques puisque
évidemment il est référence ici au
produit intérieur brut ce dernier suit
les dispositions de l'article premier de
la loi du 14 mars 2022 relative aux lois
de financement de la sécurité sociale
cette mention est destinée à rassurer
évidemment les établissements bancaires
qui ont acheté notre dette depuis 1996
et d'éventuelles investisseurs privés
intéressés par les services et les
actifs de la sécurité sociale la
présence de cet outil reflète pour nous
la dérive de la gestion des contes de
l'État et singulièrement de ses comptes
sociaux vers une financièreisation
pardon grandissante et évidemment
inquiétante ce choix se fait aux dépens
du principe de solidarité qui fonde la
sécurité sociale depuis 1945 ce sont les
impératifs de la gestion financière qui
préside au fonctionnement de nos EHPAD
par exemple dans votre lâcheté
souvenez-vous à fait en sorte que nous
ne pourrions pas aller vérifier leur
dysfonctionnement et comme l'a montré
scandale hors pa ce sont encore ses
impératifs qui vont présider demain à la
gestion de la téléconsultation et ce
dans tant d'autres domaines médicaux et
sociaux c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous voulons évidemment supprimer cet
article et puis tant qu'on parle de
travail n'oublions pas de parler de
productivité qui est quand même la
grande absente évidemment de cette des
formes et il aurait suffi de créer des
emplois à haute productivité pour que la
question ne se pose plus et qui est très
bien Madame bien plus important merci
merci bien avant de donner la parole à
Madame la rapporteur je me permets juste
voilà de répondre à Monsieur Guedj que
le gouvernement concernant certaines
dispositions il aurait pu les prendre
dans le PLFSS justement 2023 et donc ça
aurait été effectivement considéré comme
brutal il a fait le choix il a fait le
choix de passer par un bel effet SR pour
permettre au parlementaire que nous
sommes aux deux chambres de pouvoir
débattre pendant 50 jours je dis bien 50
jours donc en matière de passage en
force il y a mieux et je passe la parole
à Madame la rapporteur
merci Madame madame la Présidente alors
ça sera un avis défavorable comme vous
le savez cet article liminaire fait
partie des obligations organiques je
voudrais rappeler ici
qu'il indique les prévisions
macroéconomiques dans laquelle se pose
ce texte et qui permet d'éclairer nos
débats parlementaires il est quasi
identique à celui de la loi de finances
pour 2023 d'ailleurs il doit nous
continuer à nous alerter sur la
situation déficitaire de l'ensemble de
nos finances publiques stabilisées à 5%
du produit intérieur brut enfin cet
article comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
fait intervenir un seul changement de
400 millions d'euros pour cette année
2023 qui concerne les mesures
d'augmentation du minimum contributif du
début des retraites progressives des
mesures en faveur de la prévention et de
l'usure professionnelle je voudrais
répondre à Monsieur Guedj en disant vous
avez parlé de monstruosité juridique en
parlant de ce PLFSS rectificatif je
rappelle que
j'ai utilisé en 2014 pour le pacte de
responsabilité il me semble que vous
étiez dans la majorité pour répondre à
Madame panot effectivement le corps dit
qu'il n'y a pas de dérapage incontrôlés
cependant il dit aussi que quand vous
prenez une productive à l'horizon de 25
ans si vous prenez une productivité à
1%, je rappelle qu'elle était à 0,7% ces
10 dernières années et que vous vous
mettez dans une situation de plein
emploi avec un taux de chômage à
4,5%, le déficit en 2026 et de 11
milliards en 2030 de 13,5 milliards en
2032 de 17 milliards d'autre part
il prend aussi en compte les évolutions
récentes de deux éléments qui
déterminent un moyen et long terme la
situation financière du système de
retraite la démographie et la croissance
économique sur la démographie les
perspectives liées à la natalité ont
d'ailleurs été révisées à la baisse par
l'Insee dans un contexte post covid
d'autre part vous faites
un appel sur le sujet des fonctionnaires
et concernant les hypothèses relatives à
l'évolution de la fonction publique ce
sont les mêmes que celles qui ont été
débattus dans le cadre du projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
de stabilité globale des effectifs je
rappelle d'ailleurs que dans cette
stabilité globale nous avons su dégager
des priorités avec le financement de
15000 soignants en plus dans le cadre du
Ségur
très bien donc Madame la rapporteur avis
défavorable alors j'ai un certain nombre
de demandes d'intervention madame
Garrido vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente collègue
l'article 47 ans de la Constitution
impose au Parlement un temps contraint
pour discuter certains textes
budgétaires au motif d'un principe d'un
impératif qui est la continuité
financière de l'État chacun peut
comprendre que pour effectuer une
dépense au 1er janvier il faut l'avoir
voté avant le 31 décembre pour
implémenter une mesure financière dans
l'exercice budgétaire en cours il faut
le rectifier quand ce n'est pas prévu
d'avance mais vous voyez bien que cette
réforme des retraites parce qu'elle
remet en cause des équilibres du système
de retraite à terme voire à très long
terme ne concerne pas en réalité cet
exercice madame la rapporteur vous
l'avez reconnu vous-même nous parlons de
400 millions d'euros qui est l'envergure
de ce qui est vraiment rectificatif par
rapport à
8 milliards d'euros ainsi à l'enseigne
de ce qu'a dit mon collègue Gaid qui
parle de monstruosité juridique je
dirais plus simplement ce texte est
inconstitutionnel voilà le bon mot voilà
la réalité et vous êtes dans une fraude
une locution latine dit France
omnia Corum Pitt la fraude coron tout en
passant par cette voie abusive ou
fragilisée juridiquement et
démocratiquement ce texte les Français
vous ont vu tout au long de la
discussion budgétaire utilisée 10 fois
le 49-3 vous le dégainer comme vous
dégainer en revolver et bien maintenant
avec le 47 1 vous continuez avec le
braquage et l'escroquerie alors que nous
les députés devrions être aux premières
loges pour faire respecter la
Constitution profitez-en d'habitude je
critique la Constitution maintenant je
voudrais qu'elle s'applique parce que
justement c'est dans l'intérêt des
Français
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Viry
la parole est à Monsieur viril lui seul
à la parole mes chers collègues on
s'écoute merci merci Madame présente
peut-être un mot d'observation sur sur
ces amendements j'entends bien madame le
rapporteur c'est une obligation
organique et vous ne pouviez pas faire
autrement mais je trouve à titre
personnel maladroit d'ouvrir ce projet
de loi portant réforme des retraites par
des données purement comptable et
financières il était possible me
semble-t-il de rappeler la force
l'esprit du système de retraite par
répartition qui est avant tout une
question sociale une question
d'humanisme ça concerne des hommes et
des femmes et je trouverai réellement
qu'il y a voyay il y a une erreur de de
style il y a effectivement peut-être un
message codé qui est envoyé ou on oublie
globalement
la finalité de ce projet de loi qui est
peut-être de trouver les meilleures
solutions pour que notre système soit
plus juste et plus efficace
certes tenir les obligations
constitutionnel par un article liminaire
mais la force du régime par répartition
aurait me semble-t-il mériter quelques
lignes pour affirmer
l'utilité de notre cohésion sociale
n'oublions pas les uns les autres puis
la qualité d'une réforme c'est aussi son
acceptation sociale et de démarrer par
un article aride et financier ça me
paraît effectivement être assez saugrenu
très bien je rappelle mes chers
collègues que c'est donc une demande
d'intervention par groupe très bien
alors là j'ai une demande c'est Monsieur
turquois
oui merci madame la Présidente
je trouve dommage de commencer ce débat
par des expressions que je trouvais
excessives on pourrait peut-être revenir
à la raison ça fait maintenant trois ans
que je suis dans cette commission des
affaires sociales
ça fait maintenant trois ans que je suis
dans cette commission des affaires
sociales et
j'essaye j'essaye parce que j'écoute les
arguments de certains j'essaie de
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs voir
si on arrive à faire mieux ailleurs je
vous invite les uns les autres à
comparer avec les pays proches y compris
les pays scandinaves sur ce qui existe
il y a aucun système de protection
sociale qui soit aussi généreux que le
système français je vous invite à
regarder il y a
il y a aucun
système de retraite ou le système de
retraite par répartition soit aussi
généralisée que ça et pour autant pour
autant nous travaillons moins que nos
voisins en termes de durée à la semaine
et de durée en termes de à la vie à la
carrière donc ça c'est un premier
élément donc parce qu'il faut parfois
vouloir convaincre en démontant que ça
existe par ailleurs premier sujet
deuxième sujet concernant le corps
je regrette la présentation quand fait
le corps mais il y a tous les éléments
dans le rapport du corps en dépense vous
avez raison ils mettent que ça ça
représente une part similaire des
dépenses publiques par rapport à la
richesse par rapport au PIB par contre
il y a pas l'évocation des recettes et
si c'est un système par répartition les
recettes c'est le fruit des cotisations
du travail et quand on fait l'approche
en recette alors le déficit va croissant
sauf à le à le à l'équilibrer
massivement par de la dépense publique
comme c'est déjà le cas auteur de 30
milliards nous remettons profondément en
cause si nous ne prenons pas les mesures
la notion même de système par
répartition et je crois que nous devons
faire cet effort pour préserver quelque
chose qui est exceptionnel et qui unique
est à Monsieur de cours
mes chers collègues ces amendements sont
intéressants parce qu'ils posent une
question centrale qui est est-ce que
nous assistons pas un total détournement
du concept même de loi de financement
rectificatif de sécurité sociale
personnellement je crois que je suis le
dernier
j'ai été même rapporteur de ce texte sur
la loi organique à l'époque
et ce n'était absolument pas l'objectif
d'une noix de financement rectificative
de faire une réforme des retraites via
une loi de financement rectificative qui
intervient d'ailleurs à peine trois
semaines après la mise en oeuvre de la
loi de financement on va l'appeler
initial bien que la loi organique ne
l'appelle pas initiale de sécurité
sociale d'ailleurs dans le tableau c'est
l'objet d'ailleurs d'un amendement qui
va arriver que j'ai déposé on serait
faire au projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
mais il n'existe pas il a été même
repoussé par l'Assemblée nationale donc
on compare par rapport à quelque chose
qui n'existe pas c'est quand même
extraordinaire vous voyez et en fait
on ne veut utiliser cette loi de
rectificatif tout simplement pour faire
passer ce texte par des moyens
purement de de
procédure puisque chacun sait ce qui va
se passer
nous sommes tenus à 20 jours en fait
notre commission en trois jours doit
examiner 6000 et quelques amendements ce
qui est totalement impossible donc tout
le monde sait ce qui va se passer y
compris en séance publique oui c'est un
total détournement de procédure et moi
je voulais dire à Madame la rapporteur
est-ce qu'elle peut nous justifier du
recours à loin de financement
rectificatif de sécurité sociale pour
faire une réforme il n'y a eu que deux
cas d'utilisation des lois de
financement rectificatives et jamais
début janvier puisqu'en fait c'est début
janvier puisque le texte a été transmis
au Conseil d'État
de la loi organique
merci madame la Présidente et donc je
commencerai par salut les propos sages
et raisonnables de mon collègue de
Courson qui incarne finalement la voix
de la sagesse que votre majorité n'a pas
su trouver quand
j'entends madame la Présidente dire que
on devrait se satisfaire d'avoir un
projet de loi rectificatif en janvier
plutôt qu'un amendement dans le projet
de loi de décembre je crois rêver c'est
vraiment
justifier comme l'évoquait ma collègue
Garrido le braquage ou moi je dirais
tout simplement l'arnaque voilà en
restant modeste puisqu'en ce moment je
travaille d'ailleurs avec un collègue de
la majorité présidentielle sur les
arnaques des influenceurs mais là je
parlerai plutôt de l'arnaque faite par
le gouvernement sur la vie des
Françaises et des Français la seule
disposition et vous l'avez indiquée à
l'instant madame le rapporteur quand
vous disais qu'il y avait pas de
véritable impacts budgétaire vous le
mettez ici il y a il y a 400 millions de
de dépenses supplémentaires ou 600
millions de dépenses supplémentaires bon
on constate évidemment que cet effet est
minime sur les dépenses publiques qui
soient positifs ou négatifs et
d'ailleurs vous en couvrez sans doute
par rapport au volume total qui concerne
plusieurs centaines de milliards d'euros
par an pour le financement des retraites
c'est pourquoi nous voterons évidemment
contre enfin pour cet amendement qui
supprime cet article luminaire mais
je précise puisque nous sommes
évidemment à l'opposé de la philosophie
qui est la vôtre celle du braquage j'en
prendrai ma collègue garrideau quand
même de la procédure législative et par
ailleurs du mépris total des règles
minimales du débat parlementaire et je
ne conviendrai pas avec vous que le
Parlement soit respecté et je ne vois
pas comment en fait finalement vous
pouvez le justifier sincèrement parce
que vos mots vos mots les Françaises et
les Français ils peuvent pas les
comprendre quand vous dites
il y a trois jours pour parler de leur
vie
ou 50 jours vous dites 50 jours mais en
nombre de jours ouvrés un nombre de
jours offerts au débat et au nombre de
jours offerts à l'Assemblée nationale il
faut arrêter avec les 50 jours
finalement c'est une trentaine de jours
et finalement c'est beaucoup moins
d'heures même en travaillant de 9h du
matin à minuit c'est pas un braquage
non je voulais juste donner
attirer votre attention sur la demande
d'une prise de parole de mon collègue en
fait
alors je me permets de rappeler que
c'est une demande d'intervention par
groupe et la France insoumise c'est déjà
exprimée par l'intermédiaire par le
biais de Madame Garrido donc pour moi la
France insoumise s'est exprimée et donc
je passe la parole à Monsieur Maillard
encore
bien merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente oui je voulais juste répondre
tout à l'heure à notre collègue Ruffin
qui qui mettait en cause dans cette
audition lui rappeler que oui je
n'accepte pas et je crois que le ton
d'ailleurs de la CGC dessus c'était un
peu calmé ensuite avec cette n'acceptais
pas les propos qu'il y avait été tenus
sur le sur le sur le
je peux aller jusqu'au bout de mon
propos
il y a juste qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette notre réforme c'est garantir un
équilibre un équilibre financier pour
nos retraites les cotisations payent les
pensions les cotisations paye les
plansions qu'est-ce que vous voulez vous
voulez quoi du déficit de l'emprunt pour
payer 60% et là je vais rebondir sur ce
qu'a dit la CGC 60% à l'heure actuelle
des emprunts français pour les
déficitifs Français sont payés par des
acteurs étrangers des fonds des banques
étrangères stopper qu'est-ce que vous
voulez vous voulez qu'on continue comme
ça que l'ensemble de nos retraites soit
financé par les étrangers c'est ça la
question qu'on vous pose
très bien monsieur sangsue à la parole
merci merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais revenir sur le principe même de
ce PLFSS rectificatif il est vrai qu'on
ne peut regarder les recettes que de
2023 c'est quand même un drôle de sujet
on voit dans tout le pays 9
organisations syndicales qui s'opposent
à ce texte des millions de Français qui
sont sortis dans les rues des grèves
partout peut-être demain encore plus de
monde dans les rues et on se permet et
on se permet de passer par un véhicule
législatif complètement incongru je
pense sincèrement que ça aurait mérité
un grand débat national et un grand
débat national c'est une loi organique
qu'il prévoit de manière claire en
prenant le temps parce qu'on voit que ça
intéresse les Français alors ça ce n'est
pas acceptable de la part du
gouvernement ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose sur cet article
liminaire qui limite la dépense publique
à 0,6 qui limite la dépense publique
c'est ça on veut nous faire rentrer le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques par un véhicule qui
va permettre ou par le 47 1 ou par le
49-3 qu'il n'y ait encore une fois pas
de vote et puis enfin je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui est dit parce que
quand j'entends un monsieur turquois ou
monsieur Maillard nous expliquait qu'on
peut pas faire autrement la France alors
on dit il y a aucun système qui est
meilleur il y a aucun système qui donne
259 milliards d'euros aux entreprises en
aide aux entreprises il y a aucun
système qui a décidé d'exonérer de
cotisation sociale pour 78 milliards
d'euros les entreprises c'est ça la
réalité donc oui il y a d'autres sources
de financement possible pour assurer une
retraite juste et digne à tout le monde
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Paul
Christophe
oui merci ma Président on aura comme 50
jours pour se parler donc
j'interviendrai de temps à autre pour
apporter quelques éléments de précision
parce que j'ai entendu parler ce matin
du corps donc effectivement j'ai la
science d'ici j'ai je vais parler sous
le contrôle de Monsieur Ferracci puisque
nous étions ensemble alors vous apportez
une petite précision sur les éléments de
déficit par exemple puisque
effectivement on peut en ne changeant
aucun des paramètres évoqués de la part
madame la rapporteur encore avec 1,6 de
croissance et 4 et demi de chômage et on
retrouve un équilibre à 2070 2070 pour
retrouver l'équilibre et on aura juste
accumulé de l'ordre de 1000 milliards de
déficits sur cette période là donc c'est
juste des éléments que je livre aussi à
votre réflexion puisque on nous dit que
tout va bien dormez bien moi non je
pense pas que tout va bien juste aussi
quelques que les éléments amusants parce
que je vais pas me livrer voilà au bon
mot braquage hold-up etc on a des
experts dans la salle on a bien compris
qu'il fallait chez Arthur que les médias
s'emportent de tes propos je te les
laisse bien évidemment puisque on a
travaillé plus de rendement sur d'autres
éléments qui sont dans ce texte j'espère
qu'on y arrivera d'ailleurs à nos fameux
tucs et CVP et autres contrats
similaires pour effectivement réparer
une injustice par contre là injustice
par rapport à les situations qu'il a
l'heure aujourd'hui juste pour dire
voilà oui on peut diminuer qu'il y a pas
assez de temps pour débattre mais
j'observe quand même qu'il va nous
falloir 139 amendements déposer par le
même groupe pour évoluer la situation
savoir si on a passé de 11 à 149
salariés par exemple c'est dommage je
pense que vous auriez pu orionataire
vous met d'accord sur un seul chiffre et
puis on aura gagné un petit peu de temps
dans nos débats la même façon il faudra
à peu près char Jérôme 23 amendements
pour savoir si on fait 2050 ou 2028 à la
RATP là aussi je pense que ça aurait été
mieux nous éclairer avec une position
commune assortie bien sûr de débats à
terme que j'imagine sympathique voilà
madame la Présidente quelques mots pour
écrire merci bien avant de passer la
parole à Madame la rapporteur je passe
la parole à Madame taillée
merci madame la Présidente oui pour le
groupe écologiste juste quelques mots
monsieur Maillard disait il faut
équilibrer c'est ça le sujet en fait de
cette majorité c'est d'équilibrer
d'équilibrer le budget mais j'ai vu
monsieur Bruno Le Maire qui a dit qu'il
allait lancer un grand projet de loi
pour faire en sorte que les aides aux
entreprises soient ciblées mais je suis
sûr que sur les 160 milliards d'euros
par an qui sont donnés aux entreprises
sans contrepartie on trouvera bien 10 à
20 milliards pour cibler le régime des
retraites c'est à dire la protection
sociale pour toutes et tous donc moi ce
que je vous propose c'est de retirer ce
projet de loi là on se met tous au
travail sur les aides aux entreprises et
je suis sûr qu'on trouvera les solutions
pour financer tout ça
très bien donc mes chers collègues
seules la rapporteur à la parole s'il
vous plaît on l'écoute merci madame la
Présidente juste un mot
sur la défense de ce véhicule législatif
vous parlez de braquage d'arnaque ou de
un congru mais en fait je comprends pas
en fait je comprends pas parce que dans
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale on étudie quoi on
étudie les objectifs et les débences des
branches d'assurance maladie de la
branche autonomie la branche vieillesse
notamment donc celle qui concerne nos
retraites dans ce véhicule législatif
nous avons pu adopter depuis ces
dernières années des mesures majeures
pour nos concitoyens la lutte contre les
impayés pour les femmes célibataires le
Ségur de 20 milliards d'euros le
doublement de congé paternité la
gratuité de contraception enfin j'en
oublie donc je comprends pas je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas parler des retraites à l'endroit du
véhicule législatif où en étudie le
budget de l'assurance vieillesse c'est
c'est pas cohérent vous remarque en fait
sur ce sujet du véhicule législatif
très bien Madame la rapporteur nous
allons donc passer au vote et je mets
donc ces amendements au vote ils ont
reçu bien sûr un avis défavorable de
Madame la rapporteur qui est pour
seul je rappelle seuls les membres de la
commission peuvent voter
qui est contre
gardez bien s'il vous plaît on compte
parce que
oui mais bon
très bien qui est pour on raconte
les amendements sont rejetés je peux
vous dire d'ici je le vois
monsieur de Courson amendement suivant
monsieur de Courson vous avez la parole
pour l'amendement
5542 merci madame la Présidente il y a
quelque chose d'étrange dans l'article
premier c'est que dans le tableau on
compare les évaluations révisées 2023
enfin qui sont pratiquement pas révisés
du tout d'ailleurs puisque c'est
pratiquement les mêmes que lors du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale que nous avons adopté
en fin d'année mais on le compare au
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques mais ce projet de loi
de programmation mes chers collègues
nous l'avons repoussé
donc il n'existe pas comment peut-on
comparer quelque chose qui n'existe pas
avec une ajustement de 400 millions au
regard de 700 millions parenthèse de
dépenses des organismes de protection
sociale c'est-à-dire rien de rien
milliard oui oui milliards oui oui
c'est à dire rien alors voilà ce que je
vous propose c'est que nous supprimions
la deuxième colonne
et qu'on évite des comparaisons par
rapport à quelque chose qui n'existe pas
ceci serait cohérent avec les votes
qu'on exprimées l'Assemblée nationale en
première lecture et puisque le
gouvernement n'est pas allé au-delà de
cette première lecture
très bien monsieur le député monsieur
Bazin non pardon la rapporteur avant et
ensuite
merci madame la Présidente je regrette
que nous ne soyons pas parvenus à
adopter la loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui donnaient une
boussole plurie annuelle qui était
importante à mon avis s'agissant de
votre crainte constitutionnelle elle a
été levée par la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur la loi de finance de
2023 pour laquelle il a estimé que si le
projet de loi de programmation n'a pas
été adopté jusqu'ici il ne résulte de
cette circonstance aucune méconnaissance
de l'article premier âge de la loi
organique du 1er août 2001 ni du
principe de clarté et de sincérité du
débat parlementaire je vous propose donc
de le retirer ou à défaut défavorable
plusieurs demandes de parole monsieur
Bazin oui merci madame la Présidente
je vous comprends pas parce que
objectivement autant je vous comprends
quand vous dites c'est un article
obligatoire dans une loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale l'article
linéaire et c'est vrai que la loi
organique le prévoit est très clairement
il faut qu'on puisse présenter pour
l'exercice en quoi pour l'année à venir
l'état des prévisions de dépenses
recettes les soldes des administrations
de la sécurité sociale pour autant là
vous faites référence un texte qui n'a
pas été voté et et et je vais même plus
loin au sens du projet de loi de
programmation et finance publique il a
représentation nationale
si elle est même opposé donc je pense
mal venu de mettre cette colonne là je
pense qu'il faut la supprimer c'est
pourquoi je soutiendrai c'est un moment
de Charles de Courson sur la question de
du véhicule le penfss permet évidemment
de toucher à la branche vieillesse mais
il permet de toucher aussi aux autres
branches or là on fait l'impasse sur
toutes les autres branches d'ailleurs
qu'on a même pas examiné en séance
publique l'automne dernier puisque sur
la partie 3 qui était la partie recette
on n'a pas vu le moins d'amendement du
moins d'article or là pour le on vient
de commencer et les recevabilité on
comprend bien on peut pas créer de
charge en tant que député il y a que le
gouvernement qui qui le peut mais sur la
branche famille on peut pas envisager la
branche vieillesse sans envisager une
réforme sur la branche famille on peut
pas envisager une réforme sur la branche
vieillesse sans envisager une réforme
sur la branche ATMP d'ailleurs il y a
des fonds et ces deux branches ont été
on était ponctionnés sur la branche
maladie les négociations sont au point
mort et vous le savez bien avec les
professionnels de santé médecins kinés
sage-femme on voit bien qu'il y a un
contexte aujourd'hui on a besoin de
pouvoir modifier or là ce tableau fait
état d'une d'un scénario
identique or je pense que le scénario
n'est pas identique à celui d'à quelques
mois les hypothèses sont pas exactement
les mêmes l'inflation est persistante
plus que ce qu'on avait pu imaginer un
moment ça pose question et je crois que
il faut qu'on puisse
revisiter l'ensemble du PLFSS 2023 sur
l'ensemble des branches la parole est à
Monsieur Léo man
merci madame la Présidente écoutez c'est
amendement de mon collègue Charles de
Courson à l'avantage de vous rappeler
l'existence du Parlement cette majorité
puisque il y avait une loi de
programmation qui a été repoussée par le
Parlement vous y faites référence dans
ce texte de loin et mon collègue Charles
de Gauchon vous propose de retirer cette
référence qui serait juste en fait
respecter le vote souverain de
l'Assemblée nationale mais finalement
cet amendement il fait la démonstration
du fait que sur à peu près tout vous
piétinez le Parlement et la démocratie
vous êtes en train de le faire en
utilisant ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative vous êtes en train de le
faire en utilisant l'article 47 ans de
la Constitution vous l'avez fait 10 fois
en utilisant le 49,3 l'hiver dernier et
vous le faites finalement aussi avec ce
projet de loi puisque à la Commission
européenne vous avez dit la vérité à la
Commission européenne vous avez dit que
vous vouliez faire ce projet de loi pour
continuer à faire des cadeaux aux
entreprises et notamment la suppression
de la CVAE qui coûte 8 milliards d'euros
par an et là vous êtes en train de
vouloir nous faire faire des économies
collègues il est le moment je pense de
vous la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme et du Citoyen dont l'article 6
dit que la loi et l'expression de la
volonté générale n'est-ce pas la volonté
générale c'est l'opposition à ce projet
de loi 72 % des Français sont opposés à
ce projet de loi 90% des actifs le son
et donc si vous voulez faire de la loi à
l'expression de la volonté générale et
bien il faut retirer ce projet de loi
quand il y a 2 millions de personnes
dans la rue le 19 janvier nous ne savons
pas combien il y en aura le 31 janvier
j'espère qu'il y en aura encore plus
retirez ce projet de loin c'est
simplement de la logique si on veut
faire que la loi soit l'expression de la
volonté générale enfin simplement pour
en finir mais vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure on en a on a encore 5683
amendements à traiter ça fait 218 par
heure ça fait 3,5 par minute ça fait un
amendement toutes les 16 secondes vous
voyez bien que là aussi vous êtes en
train de piétiner le Parlement que vous
refusez le fait que nous puissions
débattre sereinement de ce projet de loi
et ça c'est votre responsabilité avec
les véhicules législatif que vous
utilisez
très bien la parole est à Madame La
Valette
Madame La Valette vous êtes perdus sur
l'amendement
5542 toujours
vous avez demandé la parole
non bon bah alors je passe Madame La
Valette
mais non mais j'ai pas demandé la parole
madame la Présidente excusez-moi et ça
doit être un peu un brouhaha mais je
n'ai pas demandé la parole
si madame la Présidente
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je crois que
cette manière de procéder cette méthode
traduit un manque de respect du
Parlement que collectivement quel que
soit les sensibilités politiques qui
sont les nôtres nous de devrions pas
accepter parce que ça nous empêche
d'avoir la vraie discussion nécessaire
sur sur ce projet de réforme le plfssr
en principe il est fait pour faire des
ajustements on voit bien qu'on n'est pas
dans un ajustement avec la réforme qui
nous est proposé donc il y a quelque
part un détournement de procédure
ensuite ici nous avons mis le doigt et
Charles de Courson avec son amendement
évidemment le fait de manière éloquente
sur
le le caractère assez saugrenu qui peut
y avoir à se référer à une loi qui n'a
pas été adoptée
et alors vous nous dites elle a pas été
adoptée mais finalement c'est pas grave
c'est comme si elle était votée quand
même c'est bon je crois pas qu'on puisse
fonctionner de cette façon là cette fois
n'a pas été adoptée nous ne pouvons pas
tout simplement nous y référer cet
amendement au bout du compte c'est tout
simplement ce que les rapporteurs ou
rapporteur aux banc appelle un
amendement de coordination donc là je
vois pas ce qui en réalité pourrait
faire obstacle à ce qu'il soit adopté
puisqu'il s'agit simplement de ne pas se
référer à une loi qui qui n'existe pas
et qui n'a pas été adopté par par le
Parlement
très bien
la parole est à Madame Rousseau
merci
là je permettais que je salue le talent
et l'expérience de monsieur de Courson
parce que c'est amendement en effet fait
référence à une loi qui n'a pas été
votée par le Parlement ça a été dit de
multiples manières et en fait le fait de
mettre cette colonne
laisserai ta pensée que nous ayons eu la
moindre le moindre accord sur la loi de
financement ce qui n'est évidemment pas
le cas donc merci à Monsieur Courson
pour cet amendement que nous
soutiendrons en groupe écologiste très
bien monsieur Guedj
oui je crois qu'il faut qu'on revienne
quand même aux sources du sujet
d'abord vous nous demandez de faire
figurer dans une loi un projet de loi je
n'ai jamais vu ça je n'ai jamais vu un
texte qui fait référence à un projet de
loi et pourquoi pas une proposition de
loi tant qu'on y est donc il y a quelque
chose qui a quand même un peu aberrant
un projet de loi ça n'existe pas c'est
un projet de loi donc renvoyer un texte
qui n'a pas été adopté c'est quand même
extrêmement problématique la deuxième
chose
la deuxième chose c'est n'oubliez pas
les raisons pour lesquelles cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques a
été rejetée pour des motifs différents
entre la droite et la gauche la droite
parce que la droite trouvait que le
texte n'était pas assez dur dans les
économies à réaliser et la gauche pour
une raison qui entre en résonance avec
ce qu'on a dans notre texte sur les dans
votre texte sur les retraites c'est que
cette trajectoire des finances publiques
2023 2027 elle intégré certaines des
hypothèses que nous contestons nous
aujourd'hui notamment le gel du point
d'indice la maîtrise des dépenses de
fonctionnaires dont on sait que pour
partie et le corps nous le dit très bien
elle alimente le déficit contre lequel
vous voulez prendre des mesures à
travers l'allongement de l'âge légal
donc vous ne pouvez pas nous imposer là
aussi non seulement un projet de loi qui
n'est pas adopté mais sans oublier les
raisons pour lesquelles on a rejeté ce
projet de loi notamment le fait qu'il y
a cette trajectoire de finances
publiques qui contient les raisons même
d'être qui vous appelle à faire cette
réforme des retraites j'espère que vous
avez compris comment le serpent se mord
la queue c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous soutiendrons l'amendement de
monsieur de Courson très bien monsieur
Grelier
oui merci madame la Présidente quelques
observations sur en réponse à notre
collègue qui a fait référence tout à
l'heure à l'article 6 de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et des citoyens je
ne suis interrogé en l'écoutant pour
savoir qui finalement manquait de
respect au Parlement celui qui nous dit
que la loi et l'expression de la volonté
générale mais la loi dans la
constitution de la 5ème République et
votée par le Parlement ou celui qui nous
explique que la volonté générale qui
ferait la loi s'exprime à coup de
sondage ou à coup de français dans les
rues au moment des manifestations donc
moi il me semble que ceux qui respectent
la loi sont ceux qui sont ici autour de
ces tables et qui vont à un moment voter
cette réforme donc je vous renvoie mon
cher collègue à vos études de droit
constitutionnel elle me paraissent utile
et urgente
très bien
oui je passe la parole à Madame la
rapporteur et ensuite on passe au vote
juste pour essayer de rassurer la loi de
finances 2023 elle a été adoptée avec le
même tableau concernant la loi de
programmation alors certes qui n'a pas
été adopté à l'Assemblée mais qui était
voté au Sénat par ailleurs donc on a
déjà adopté la loi de finances 2023 de
la même façon en fait très bien donc je
mets aux voix cet amendement qui a reçu
un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est contre
29 pour 27 comptes
l'amendement est adopté
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur dareville pour
le 6942 à Monsieur jumelle
bon l'amendement qu'on vient d'adopter
me conduit à vous transmettre le 06 de
Laurent Fabius pour tester la
constitutionnalité de votre mauvais
projet
sur le fond maintenant je veux vous dire
ce qui traverse mon esprit depuis
quelques semaines on s'est pris le covid
sur la tête
qui a révélé à quel point l'hôpital
était malade
les Français vivent mal dans leur chair
l'uppercute de l'inflation qui fait mal
au vieux et qui transforme les débuts de
moi en fin de mois la crise de l'énergie
bouscule l'économie réelle
qu'est-ce qu'on peut bien mériter les
français pour que vous puissiez leur
taper à nouveau sur la tronche avec ce
mauvais projet des retraites
la réponse à ça est assez simple au bout
du compte vous avez un gouvernement de
banquier et vous faites la démonstration
qu'il est désormais un gouvernement
d'apothicaire de comptable l'article 1
vise à faire allégeance à Bruxelles en
inscrivant dans la Constitution dans la
loi pardon l'objectif d'austérité vous
avez choisi de faire payer les pauvres
parce qu'ils sont les plus nombreux vous
avez décidé de caler la finance et vous
en prendre à la France des usines à la
France qui travaille à celles qui a fait
tourner le pays pendant la crise c'est
la raison pour laquelle avec cet
amendement nous vous proposons d'assumer
cela et d'inscrire donc dans l'article
un luminaire votre volonté de satisfaire
les exigences de l'Europe en inscrivant
l'austérité dans les objectifs
principaux de votre loi
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis sur cet amendement de Monsieur
Daredevil enfin Monsieur jumelle
merci Madame l'important on a déjà
commencé à détourner l'article liminaire
grâce à l'amendement précédent là vous
poursuivez le détournement de l'objet de
l'article liminaire mais je voudrais
revenir sur quelques points dit à
l'occasion de la défense de cet
amendement par Monsieur Jumel vous dites
qu'on veut faire payer les pauvres juste
dans ce texte et on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais dans ce texte qui est
présenté aujourd'hui les mesures
d'accompagnement elle favorisent les 30%
les plus pauvres je passe aussi sur la
France des usines où on pourrait saluer
la réaugmentation du nombre d'emplois
industriels dans notre pays par exemple
donc c'est un avis défavorable
très bien donc monsieur daryville oui
merci madame la Présidente
concernant cet amendement où vous avez
bien compris madame la rapporteur
général que il s'agit de vous aider à
préciser vous-même les objectifs que
vous n'affichez pas forcément dans ce
texte puisque les 06% ils sont inscrits
dans dans le tableau mais j'en profite
pour vous faire observer qu'il y a
beaucoup de chiffres qui ne sont pas
communiqués c'est-à-dire tous les autres
en réalité qui n'ont pas été communiqués
par le gouvernement donc ce tableau
visait à faire cela mais je veux dire
pour que les choses soient très claires
que comme nous ne souscrivons pas ces
objectifs évidemment nous ne le voterons
pas
très bien monsieur Boyard oui je pense
que c'est important de préciser les
objectifs
vous savez le Nouveau Monde il a quand
même une drôle de tête parce que en 1983
vous avez Balladur qui arrive et qui dit
les caisses sont vides il va falloir
décaler on passe la retraite de 60 à 65
ans ensuite vous avez ensuite ensuite
vous avez ensuite vous avez 2003 fillons
qui arrivent et qui dit ensuite les
caisses sont vides il va falloir tout
revider ensuite vous avez würt qui
arrive qui dit les caisses sont vides il
va falloir il va falloir encore décaler
vous arrivez en 2014 on arrive on nous
dit les caisses sont vides il va encore
falloir décaler finalement vous prenez
les baladures vous prenez les filles on
vous prenez les fleurs vous prenez les
touraines vous leur mettez un col roulé
et ce sont des macronistes ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que au vu de tout
ce que vous êtes en train de faire
depuis 5 10 ans et tout ce qui arrête
pas de se décaler se pose la question de
moi du haut de mes 22 ans à quel âge
est-ce que je vais pouvoir partir non
mais mes chers collègues est-ce que vous
êtes capable de vous discipliner un
petit peu à partir du moment où vous
explique quelque chose non mais
donc
si je demande ce que je vous venez
pardon attendez attendez il y en a une
qui vous êtes sérieuse parce que vous
êtes en train de faire là non mais vous
prenez pour qui monsieur Boyard non mais
attendez madame madame je prends la je
prends la parole il y a un droit général
dans la salle une députée j'aimerais
bien qu'on maintienne un peu l'ordre à
partir du moment où j'essaie d'expliquer
quelque chose
je vous le demande madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député à la parole
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
terminez monsieur le député on fait une
pause de 5 minutes je ne peux pas
terminer entendez le droit dans la pièce
chaque fois que je prends la parole dans
cette commission il y a un droit dans la
pièce
s'il vous plaît
on ouvre les chakras et on se tait
donc ma question ma question était celle
de quels étaient les objectifs au vu de
toutes les réformes qui ont été faites
est-ce que plus tard on se retrouvera
encore à avoir un décalage de l'âge de
départ à la retraite dans la mesure où
tous les cinq disons on se retrouve à
avoir des réformes c'est une question
que j'ai pour Madame la rapporteur très
bien Madame la rapporteur vous souhaitez
répondre oui non
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues s'il
vous plaît on s'interpelle pas s'il vous
plaît juste redire un madame la
rapporteur va répondre un petit voyage
de cette réforme et de revenir à un
équilibre et de permettre de arrêter
d'endetter puisqu'on s'est en plus que
la charge de la dette augmente de façon
monsieur Boyard s'il vous plaît
redire à Monsieur Boyard que l'objectif
même de cette réforme est de revenir à
l'équilibre d'ici 2030 et de diminuer
les dettes liées si on ne faisait pas
cette réforme c'est l'objectif même de
ce texte
très bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté avant de faire la pause
mes chers collègues je mets aux voix
l'article liminaire ainsi modifier qui
est pour l'article luminaire
qui est pour
c'est l'article linéaire
oui qui est contre
soit
donc 25 27 août 27 septembre
très bien on raconte les pour qui est
pour
mais on n'a pas on les a pas comptés
29 pour
27 contre l'amendement l'Arctique pardon
est adopté je fais une pause de 10
minutes
madame fossillon
oui un amendement qui vous propose donc
de supprimer ce titre en fait c'est un
appel à la sincérité chers collègues
puisqu'il n'est nullement question avec
votre recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite d'équilibrer les comptes de la
Sécurité sociale et des retraites
d'autres collègues l'ont dit avant moi
mais vous répondez là avec engagement et
détermination à la Commission européenne
vous ne voulez absolument pas sauver le
système de retraite par répartition on
rappelle quand même que c'est le même
que vous avez voulu détruire en 2019
c'est pas le système que vous voulez
sauver le système que vous voulez sauver
c'est celui
du tout profit celui qui vous permet
toujours plus de dévaloriser la valeur
du travail c'est-à-dire la richesse
produite par celles et ceux qui
travaillent les travailleurs et les
travailleuses donc ne mentez pas
sur le fait que vous voudriez sauver ce
système de retraite et en plus la
méthode employée aujourd'hui ne
permettra pas sur le cours le moyen et
le long terme à un équilibre qui
permettrait plus d'égalité je pense à
l'égalité homme-femme vous voulez
pouvoir continuer de la même de vos
ministres abaisser les impôts aux
grosses entreprises vous voulez par la
même continuer à déverser des milliards
et des milliards d'argent public au très
grosses entreprises privées et j'en veux
pour preuve d'ailleurs vos deux lignes
argumentaires assez contradictoires d'un
jour un ministre nous explique qu'il va
falloir que les Français fassent des
efforts et de l'autre vous nous
expliquer que c'est des mesures de
grandes justice sociale personne n'est
dupe dans la population plus vous
argumentez moins les Français vous
croient et nous serons je l'espère et
j'en suis sûr nombreuses et nombreux
demain dans la rue pour vous faire
renoncer
très bien Madame la rapporteur oui je
voudrais commencer en revenant sur le
dernier propos que vous avez eu sur le
fait de dire on est on est d'accord de
dire que c'est des mesures d'effort que
nous demandons à nous tous avec ce
décalage de l'âge de départ à la
retraite mais c'est aussi des mesures de
justice sociale cet amendement vous
voulez changer le titre et retirer le
fait de revenir à l'équilibre peut-être
qu'on diverge sur la manière que vous
envisageriez de de gérer ces déficits
qui sont bien précisées par le corps
mais
il n'y a pas de raison de changer ce
titre puisque nous allons bien vers un
rééquilibrage par rapport à ces déficits
donc la vie défavorable
très bien alors donc j'ai monsieur Cyril
liseac Siby qui a demandé la parole
merci Madame présidente chaque collègue
nous avons trois jours pour gamily ce
texte en commission trois jours précieux
je constate malheureusement que le
gâteau 2h nous passons ce temps précieux
à Paris véhicules législatif plvss et
qui parlementaire loi programmation des
finances publiques depuis deux heures
beaucoup de vocabulaire véhément
beaucoup de commentons et rien sur le
fond
chers collègues oui nous examinons un
texte pour équilibrer la sécurité
sociale que soit ton doux c'est la
préserver sur quel principe est-il basé
il est basé sur deux principes le
travail et la répartition le travail des
plus grands nombres et la répartition de
cotisations employeur et employée
pourquoi le rééquilibrer parce que
aujourd'hui ce système est déjà
déficitaire de 30 milliards d'années 30
milliards tous les ans
on est déjà sorti de la répartition si
on ne fera rien si on ne fait rien on
sortira complètement de cette
répartition et le corps qu'on lise le
rapport dans un sens ou dans l'autre
nous dit que les visites cumulées de
système en 2050 sera de 500 milliards
qui soient équilibre en demi-70
s'intéresse qui si dans cette salle
chers collègues nous ici nous partageons
la même volonté celui de préserver ce
trésor qui est la sécu qui est le
système pas répartition ne rien faire
sera remettre en cause notre civilis
social la retraite pour les futurs
générations et le niveau de pension de
retraite comme l'indiqué le premier
président de la Cour des comptes oui
Messieurs mes collègues communistes oui
nous sommes là pour préserver et
équilibrer le système
très bien la parole est à Madame Prisca
Thévenot
merci madame la Présidente très chère
collègues j'entends tout à fait votre
demande qui est de dire que les
entreprises le capital doivent
participer au financement des retraites
et j'ai envie de vous dire ben c'est
déjà le cas en fait elle participe déjà
avec le forfait social à hauteur de 6
milliards d'euros notamment sur les
contributions au retraites chapeau aux
jetons administrateur au contribution
sur la prévoyance complémentaire elle
participe notamment à 800 millions
d'euros sur la distribution d'action
gratuite elle participe aussi à 5
milliards d'euros sur la C3S c'est la
contribution sociale de solidarité des
sociétés elle contribue aussi sur la
taxe des salaires alors oui la taxe des
salaires ça porte mal son nom en réalité
c'est l'impôt sur les sociétés vous
allez nous dire qu'il faut continuer à
imposer toujours plus très bien allons-y
franchement aiguillement j'aimerais
juste simplement vous rappeler que 99%
de nos entreprises en France ce sont des
TPE des PME qui ont juste demandé leur
fin de mois et qui ont souvent du mal à
embaucher alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez vous voulez qu'on continue à les
imposer le problème avec cette démarche
là c'est que demain avec cette solution
il ne s'agira plus d'augmenter les
salaires mais de trouver des salaires
très bien Madame la Députée la parole
est un monsieur
madame pardon tailler Pollion pardon
elle est juste en face de moi merci
madame la Présidente oui cette réforme
contrairement à ce que dit Madame la
rapporteur n'est pas une réforme de
justice c'est une réforme de dégradation
de la situation pour les travailleurs et
les travailleurs puisqu'il s'agit de
travailler deux ans de plus alors ce que
vous présentez comme des mesures de
justice sont en réalité des mesures
d'atténuation tout au plus et
d'atténuation tout à fait ridicule au
regard de la situation notamment sur la
pénibilité sur sur l'emploi des seniors
etc d'ailleurs c'est Madame borne qui le
disait très bien enfin très bien elle
disait quand on lui demandait mais
est-ce que les personnes les plus
modestes vont bénéficier de la réforme
est-ce que cette réforme ne va pas les
peigner les pénaliser elle disait mais
non ils vont travailler le moins le plus
la formule est montre toute la
complexité intellectuelle mais surtout
le fait qu'ils vont travailler plus
malgré toutes les questions de
pénibilité malgré toutes les questions
d'accès à l'emploi pour les personnes
qui sont
souvent pour inaptitude ou en raison de
leur âge donc voilà la situation c'est
celle-ci et donc ce n'est pas une projet
de loi pour la sécurité sociale ce n'est
pas un projet de loi sociale c'est un
projet de loi qui a communiqué fin
d'équilibrer les comptes que vous
déséquilibrez sans arrêt par votre
politique fiscale injuste et Madame
Thévenot disait oui les entreprises on
peut pas leur demander de cotiser de de
cotiser plus mais aujourd'hui votre
politique fiscale est l'avantage
énormément les multinationales qui
pourraient elle payer davantage et
l'injustice fiscale c'est aussi un
déséquilibre les petites entreprises
payent beaucoup plus et tout ce travail
d'un Justin de lutte contre l'injustice
fixée entre les entreprises vous ne
l'avez pas fait donc je vous appelle
encore retirez ce projet de loi
travaillons sur la participation des
entreprises
au financement de notre pacte social et
là vous allez voir on va trouver la
justice fiscale entre les petites et les
grandes et on va trouver des moyens pour
la protection de notre système social
très bien monsieur Delaporte oui merci
madame la Présidente on évoque des
questions d'équilibre vous dites il faut
équilibrer la sécurité sociale mais pour
cela vous déséquilibrez la vie des
Françaises et des Français depuis
maintenant 5 ans vous n'avez cessé de
faire des faire des économies aux
entreprises par exemple le taux global
les cotisations sociales du par les
employeurs est passé en 2017 d'environ
15% à 7% en 2022 voilà ce que vous avez
fait depuis 2017 vous n'avez eu de cesse
de faire de creuser le trou de la
Sécurité sociale en faisant des cadeaux
aux entreprises et maintenant vous
voulez faire payer ce coût aux
travailleurs aux salariés aux Français
et aux Français qui ont des carrières
pénibles carrière hachées et cela cela
en effet sa déséquilibre les vies donc
cette amendement c'est juste un
amendement qui vient rectifier le sens
de votre réforme et qui veut juste
rééquilibrer finalement la réforme en
supprimant cet article et son sens
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Monet
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur faut être sérieux quand vous
dites on demande de faire des efforts à
tous les rentiers qui ont perçu 80
milliards de dividendes en 2022 on leur
demande pas d'efforts ensuite vous
expliquer
parce que aujourd'hui il y a pas de
déficit donc vous expliquer c'est en
prévision d'un déficit je vous rappelle
quand même qu'effectivement si on laisse
le monde du travail tel qu'il est
actuellement il y aura certainement un
déficit mais je vous rappelle que vous
avez rejeté toutes nos propositions
d'augmentation des salaires qui aurait
permis de faire rentrer de l'argent dans
les caisses
vous parlez des contes de la Sécu mais
vous en avez rien à faire dès qu'on doit
laisser que je vous rappelle qu'on avait
on avait anéanti la dette de la Sécu au
détour d'un amendement qui transférait
la dette covid sur le budget de l'État
ce qui avait annulé la dette de la
sécurité sociale et vous l'avez rejeté
donc les contes de la Sécu c'est pas
vraiment votre problème le fond c'est
que vous vous plaidez pour une baisse
des dépenses publiques nous on plaide
pour une augmentation des recettes
publiques
très bien la parole est à Madame Autun
oui merci nous étions en 2019 dans cette
salle est déjà à l'époque vous aviez la
volonté d'imposer un système à points
une véritable usine à gaz et nous avons
réussi à faire en sorte que cette loi ne
soit pas adoptée
grâce à la mobilisation grâce à la
bataille d'amendements et puis en 2023
nous revoilà dans cette salle avec votre
volonté encore d'abîmer notre système
par répartition et d'abîmer les droits
donc en réalité vous ne voulez pas
sauver le régime comme vous le prétendez
aujourd'hui mais l'utiliser pour
répondre à une obsession quelle est la
réduction de la dépense publique et
d'ailleurs c'est écrit dans des
documents très officiels dans le budget
2023 dans le programme de stabilité que
vous avez signé à l'échelle européenne
et comme vous ne voulez pas
maintenir la CVAE que l'impôt de
production à hauteur de 8 milliards
d'euros comme vous ne voulez pas revenir
sur vos mesures au service des plus
riches je pense à l'ISF je pense à la
flat tag je pense aux milliards qui ont
été donnés sans contrepartie aux grandes
entreprises comme vous êtes obsédé par
cela par cette politique qui est une
politique
profondément injuste et au service des
privilégiés alors vous trouvez le moyen
de taper sur le régime de retraite pour
compenser ses largesses qui ont été
donnés au plus puissant et au plus
privilégié c'est ça le cœur de la
réforme et sur laquelle ce qui est très
insupportable et je pense que la vie
devrait s'inviter dans ce commission
parce qu'on ne peut pas parler que de
chiffres et techniques ce dont il s'agit
là c'est du corps des gens c'est de la
vie des plus modestes parce que ceux qui
vont le plus payer le prix de votre
choix qui est un choix d'une certaine
manière indigne pas simplement injuste
indigne indécent j'ai presque envie de
dire il y a de l'indécence à demander à
des gens qui ont commencé tôt à
travailler qui font des métiers pénibles
et répétitifs de leur dire vos deux plus
belles années de retraite vous allez
vous asseoir dessus comme si il n'y a
pas de carte immense d'espérée vous
allez voler les meilleurs amis de
retraite notamment au plus modestes
merci madame la Présidente alors
effectivement on parle d'équilibrage
équilibrage entre dépenses et recettes
mais permettez-moi de vous dire quand
même dans cette salle que si on se
limite à ça en équilibre dans le vide en
fait tant que les trois leviers
fondamentaux qui qui soutiennent ce
cette retraite sont le plein emploi la
productivité la natalité tant qu'on ne
s'attaquera pas à ça on équilibre dans
le vide je vous rappelle qu'il y a
absolument aucune politique nataliste
d'envergure alors qu'évidemment ce sont
typiquement bêtement les bébés de 2023
qui seront les cotisants de 2043 si on y
avait réfléchi 10 ans avant et ben ça
aurait été les bébés de 2013 qui
auraient vous imaginez bien cotisé 20
ans après donc sans aucune politique
nataliste vous équilibrez dans le vide
madame la rapporteur tout à l'heure vous
vous gargarisiez du plein emploi mais en
fait les emplois qui ont été créés sous
l'air Macron sont des emplois qui ont
une très faible valeur ajoutée ce qu'il
faut c'est augmenter leur productivité
encore une fois un livreur
uber eats ne payedalera jamais à 200 km
heure ce qu'il faut faire c'est avoir
une politique ambitieuse
réindustrialisation de la France je vous
rappelle que depuis 2017 on a simplement
45 000 emplois qui ont été créés dans
l'industrie manufacturière et la
productivité vous aviez l'air aussi
assez content de ce chiffre de 1 déjà
c'est en dessous de 1 et je vous
rappelle quand même que la moyenne de
l'OCDE c'est 5,7 donc en fait plus on va
avancer dans ce texte et plus on va bien
voir votre projet c'est en fait faire
payer aux Français les mauvais choix
politiques que vous avez fait et qui ont
appauvri la France
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Juvin
oui madame la Présidente c'est donc
effectivement une question d'équilibre
que nous évoquons tous d'abord ce qui
est formidable avec le corps c'est que
chacun y trouve ce qu'il veut et on a à
la fois ceux qui disent oui il y a des
équilibre qui disent regardez le corps
et ceux qui disent non il y a pas du
tout de déséquilibre et qui disent la
preuve il faut lire le rapport du corps
que dit le rapport du corps le rapport
du corps dit la chose suivante on va les
guillemets après avoir enregistré des
excédents en 2021 et 2022 le système de
retraite sera déficitaire en moyenne sur
les 25 prochaines années voilà ce que
dit le rapport du corps d'ailleurs un
agent de catégorie C de la fonction
publique territoriale ni après 1980 s'il
part à la retraite avec le système
actuel il part à la retraite avec une
rente qui le met sous le seuil de
pauvreté alors faut-il baisser la
dépense publique j'entends cet argument
en permanence ben oui pourquoi il faut
baisser la dépense publique parce que il
y a pas d'argent public l'argent public
c'est toujours l'argent qu'on prend dans
la poche des impôts c'est à dire
toujours l'argent qu'on prendra la poche
des Français alors oui les comptes sont
déséquilibrés oui il n'y a pas d'argent
public magique c'est l'argent des
Français et sans réforme et bien les
jeunes n'auront pas de retraite
très bien je vais passer la parole à
Madame la rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente quelques
remarques
quelques remarques alors Monsieur
monsieur Delaporte vous dites que les
taux de cotisation ont baissé si on se
concentre sur les cotisations les
ressources pour la sécurité sociale
l'ensemble des cotisations brutes et
passer 257 milliards à 292 milliards
d'euros en 2023 entre 2019-2023 c'est
une augmentation de 35 milliards d'euros
ensuite vous parlez madame taillée
polluant de justice sociale nous allons
tout au long du texte revoir les mesures
de justice sur les carrières longues sur
les petites pensions etc mais nous
allons
est-ce que le principal motif de justice
sociale de ce projet de loi n'est pas de
conserver un système par répartition
pour moi c'est le premier
argument de justice sociale de pouvoir
être à l'équilibre et donc de permettre
la non disparition du système par
répartition Madame La Valette vous dites
que les emplois que nous avons créés
n'entraînent pas de valeur ajoutée
pourtant les emplois créés grâce aux
exonérations sont sur les les salariés
les plus modestes donc je trouve moi
personnellement que c'est une valeur
ajoutée que ces emplois Béné au plus
modeste
très bien donc nous allons passer mes
chers collègues au vote donc je mets aux
voix donc c'est amendement qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté
amendement suivant pas défendu
je pense pas non
nous allons passer mes chers collègues à
l'article 1er avec des amendements de
plusieurs amendements de suppression
monsieur Guedj pour le 935
oui madame la Présidente nous aurons
l'occasion évidemment de
détailler cette obsession à la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
qui s'inscrit dans cette illusion
originelle martelée à longueur
d'éléments de langage qui est que le
système étant déficit et que par
conséquent il faut des mesures de purge
et au-delà de celle relatives à
l'allongement de l'âge légal à cette
impôt sur la vie il y a toutes celles
qui viennent
s'attaquer à ceux de ces régimes que les
réformes précédentes avaient jugé
pertinent de maintenir
UE égard à la spécificité des missions
qui sont conduites c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'emblée nous vous propos avec
ce premier amendement de supprimer
l'article qui prévoit l'extinction la
suppression de l'ensemble des régimes
spéciaux de retraite indiquées notamment
ceux relatif aux industries électriques
et gazières à la Banque de France à la
RATP etc très bien donc monsieur
abiranier n'est pas là Monsieur califer
pour votre amendement le 1344
bonjour à tous écoutez soyez pas vous
dise que nous ne sommes pas d'accord
avec le projet de loi et que nous sommes
pour le métier du modèle social tel
qu'il est et que nous sommes un moment
il faut de la pèsement après trois
années de covid et nous sommes dans un
moment de dépression avec la hausse des
prix et que le la population les
ouvriers le monde du travail aurait
besoin d'un peu de sérénité et cet
amendement veille à poser un temps de
d'apaisement et s'il a raison pour
laquelle nous devons nous pour justement
là pour ne pas supprimer tout de suite
les régimes spéciaux d'autant plus que
ils avaient bien résisté à la réforme de
2008 les syndicats ne veulent pas il y a
six personnes qui disent sur 10 qui
manifestent l'homme contentement nous
sommes des représentants du peuple nous
demandons donc pas supprimer les régimes
spéciaux dans ce texte là très bien
pardon
notre amendement vise à ne pas supprimer
très bien
la parole est à Monsieur de la porte oui
merci madame la Présidente pour aller en
complément de ce que disait mes
collègues aujourd'hui finalement vous
allez plus loin plus dur plus violemment
que ce que faisait Nicolas Sarkozy en
son temps et je salue ce qu'il reste de
mes collègues LR ici présent
nous sommes ici
nous sommes ici nous sommes ici
mobilisés en tant que partie ayant subi
l'arrivée des macronistes mais qui ont
finalement réussi à braconner sur les
terres de celles et ceux qui sont encore
présents
je dirais simplement que les régimes
spéciaux visent une chose
ils vise ils vise simplement à faire en
sorte que des métiers durs des métiers
pénibles dans lesquels il y a des
astreintes fréquentes et une usure
physique puisse donner lieu à un certain
nombre de compensations nous avons un
amendement de suppression générale de
cet article puisque nous sommes opposés
à cette mesure injuste qui concernera un
ensemble de métiers qui restent pénible
nous vous amènerons aussi dans les
amendements qui viennent à devoir vous
prononcer sur la réalité de la
suppression de ces régimes un par un
parce qu'il faudra nous expliquer en
quoi ils sont injustes en quoi ils sont
pénibles en quoi ils nécessitent pas des
mesures spécifiques d'aménagement de ces
carrières et chers collègues nous aurons
l'occasion d'avoir ce débat si vous
refusez de revenir en arrière sur cette
mesure générale de suppression
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Petavy
merci madame la Présidente alors notre
groupe souhaite supprimer cet article
titank a fermé des régimes spéciaux
alors la grande question est pourquoi
cela plutôt que d'autres ne le sait le
groupe écologiste y opposé parce que
c'est encore un débat qui sera sans
parler du travail sans parler de la
pénibilité et sans parler du repos la
philosophie des régimes spéciaux c'est
de reconnaître que le travail est
pénible or dans ce texte il faut le dire
rien n'est fait pour être à la hauteur
de cet enjeu mais c'est tout l'enjeu de
notre débat sur le travail au fond
plutôt que de réformer les retraites par
le haut en remettant le travail à sa
juste place on effectue on effectue un
nivellement par le bas alors le groupe
écologiste a une boussole qui est
essentielle le droit à la vie digne
un travail digne et à pouvoir se reposer
dignement c'est-à-dire pas abîmer il est
donc proposé de supprimer cet article
très bien la parole est à Madame
Rousseau
alors c'est supprimer cet article aurait
vraiment beaucoup d'intérêt puisqu'en
fait on voit bien qu'il y a un
renversement de la sémantique dans les
débats que nous avons sur sur cette
réforme des retraites on transforme
quelque chose qui protège les plus
précaires et ceux qui ont les métiers
les plus pénibles en une forme de
privilège qu'ils auraient et que nous
devrions abolir alors que précisément ce
sont des régimes spéciaux qui protègent
les personnes qui sont les plus exposées
et quand vous parlez d'usure
professionnelle ont lieu et place de
pénibilité et bien en fait on la voit
bien aussi l'espèce de manœuvre
sémantique que vous exercez pour faire
en sorte que ce soit de notre
responsabilité de la responsabilité de
celles et ceux dont les corps sus plutôt
que de l'employeur et de la pénibilité
des métiers la réalité que nous devrions
augmenter le nombre de régimes spéciaux
et particulièrement en faire par exemple
pour les aides à domicile pour les
personnels d'entretien pour toutes les
personnes les aides-soignantes etc qui
ont des métiers pénibles et qui ont une
mauvaise reconnaissance de leur
pénibilité précisément parce qu'il n'y a
pas l'historique des combats sociaux
qu'il peut y avoir dans d'autres métiers
et notamment dans l'industrie donc la
réalité est que là vous êtes à
contre-courant complètement de la
reconnaissance de la réalité du travail
et particulièrement des plus précaires
et vraiment nous nous honorions à
supprimer cet article
très bien Madame la Députée monsieur
Daredevil
les libéraux dans une forme de
continuité faut une fixette
sur les régimes spéciaux vous décidez
de privilégier
les régimes spéciaux des bourses
et vous décidez de déclarer la guerre
aux cheminots aux électriciens gaziers
aux agents de la RATP
on épargnant ceux qui font du pognon en
dormant je dis ça parce que les réformes
qui ont percuté les régimes spéciaux ont
déjà fait leur mauvaise oeuvres la loi
Fillon de 2003 les décrets du 30 juin
2008 portant réglement des régimes
spéciaux la loi de novembre 2010 portant
déjà réforme des retraites le décret de
2012 va vous avez une forme de cohérence
dans votre fixette de vous en prendre
cheminots aux électriciens gaziers aux
agents de la RATP comme si les
privilèges étaient de ce côté là comme
s'il n'avait pas de suggestions de
service avec des horaires atypiques une
pénibilité qui devrait au contraire
servir d'exemple pour prendre en compte
les corps usés dans le régime général
vous nous proposez avec ce texte de
banquier avec ce texte de comptable de
niveler par le bas le système des
retraites offert aux Français
retenez qu'avec les minions français qui
seront dans la rue demain nous serons
toujours du côté de la France qui
travaillent de ceux qui ont été au
charbon pendant le covid pour faire
tourner le pays de ceux dont on a besoin
au quotidien pour maintenir des liens
pour faire des solidarités pour
réaffirmer la présence du service public
partout et pour tous et puis je vous
invite à faire une chose allez voir
allez voir les Lignières sur les lignes
à haute tension et dites-leur que votre
système de banquier est plus pénible que
le travail qu'ils exercent allez voir
les Atsems qui s'occupent de nos mômes
et expliquer leur que le régime spécial
de la de la fonction publique
territoriale est un privilège de luxe de
calme et de volupté allez voir allez
voir les agents cheminots
madame kéké vous avez la parole madame
keke vous avez la parole et elle seule à
la parole
merci madame la Présidente
nous vous demandons de supprimer ce
quartier par la suppression des régimes
spéciaux vous voulez opposer les
Français les uns aux autres comme
toujours vous cherchez toujours à
accuser certains métiers et leurs
salariés des privilégiés mais pourquoi
c'est pour mieux protéger les vrais
privilégiés et que le gouvernement
favorise dans ces réformes derrière
cette suppression des régimes spéciaux
il y a une attaque contre toutes les
travailleuses et travailleurs c'est la
retraite à 64 et la célébration de la
loi Touraine les Français vous disent
non nous vous le disons aussi et ça sera
le 31 dans la rue merci
très bien la parole est à Monsieur cloué
oui ce sera monsieur legaffre oui
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut supprimer cet
article et maintenir les régimes
spéciaux d'abord parce que comme cela
vient d'être dit à chaque fois qu'on
s'en prend en retraite on cherche à
opposer les Français entre eux le
problème c'est que les Français ont très
bien compris le contenu de votre effort
mais qu'il a une très large majorité il
n'en veulent pas ensuite de quoi
s'agit-il avec cette suppression des
régimes spéciaux rappelons que les
salariés concernés conservent leur
régime d'assurance maladie et d'accident
du travail ce simple fait donne le
contenu de votre réforme
qui est de réduire les retraites point
barre enfin supprimer les régimes
spéciaux c'est une mesure de régression
et de nivellement par le bas cela a été
dit mais je voudrais rappeler que ces
régimes spéciaux sont d'abord et avant
tout des régimes pionniers avant 1945
existait les régimes de mineurs les
régimes de cheminots des fonctionnaires
de la RATP en 1946 c'est le régime de DF
qui est fondé ce sont ces régimes qui
ont établis les prestations définies qui
ont établi le salaire de remplacement ce
sont ces régimes qui ont établi les
catégories actives celle-là même qu'avec
la réforme que nous examinons en ce
moment madame borne veut faire
travailler deux ans de plus
alors
tous les droits en matière de retraite
viennent des régimes spéciaux et s'ils
ont été maintenus en 1946 c'était dans
un objectif que le régime général
rejoigne les droits acquis dans le cadre
de ces régimes pionniers ce n'est
toujours pas le cas il est donc
nécessaire de maintenir ces régimes
spéciaux de les défendre et nul doute
que les salariés concernés par ces
régimes spéciaux le feront demain en se
mettant massivement en grève et nous les
soutenons totalement
très bien la parole est à Madame panot
assez vous allez-y madame la députée
alors je vais éteindre le micro allez-y
merci madame la Présidente d'abord je
crois qu'il est bon de rappeler que les
régimes spéciaux ne sont pas des
privilèges c'est Ambroise Croizat qui
disait ne parlez pas d'acquis sociaux
mais de conquis sociaux et pour cause
donc les régimes par exemple de DF de la
RATP prévoit de meilleurs anticipations
de départ en retraite et une meilleure
prise en compte de la pénibilité parce
que les travailleurs dans ces secteurs
subissent une espérance de vie qui est
souvent inférieure alors
l'argument qui est brandi ici c'est
celui de la justice sociale et de
l'équité mais la justice sociale et
l'équité ce serait justement d'appliquer
de telles mesures à toutes les
travailleuses à tous les travailleurs
qui accomplissent des travaux pénibles
et donc de les étendre aux branches et
au régime qui n'en disposent pas
actuellement et ainsi au lieu d'avoir un
nivellement par le bain nous aurions au
contraire une harmonisation par le haut
on se souvient très bien que la
rhétorique qui qualifie les régimes
spéciaux de privilèges c'était
précisément le point d'entrée du
gouvernement en 2019 pour opposer les
Français et faire passer la retraite à
point donc c'est un comble d'entendre
vanter le système par répartition
maintenant puisque c'est exactement
celui que le gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron voulait abattre il y a 4 ans à
peine de toute façon plus personne ne
vous écoute tellement vous serez capable
d'affirmer que les fraises sont bleues
et que tous ceux qui disent l'inverse
sont des populistes ou des extrémistes
oui bah écoutez c'est le niveau qu'il
faut pour vous répondre vous vouliez
mettre fin au régime spéciaux sous
prétexte de justice sociale entre les
futurs retraités chez vous la justice
sociale c'est une façon de ne pas dire
que tout le monde devra partir deux ans
plus tard à la retraite et donc nous
saurons en soutien à toutes celles et
tous ceux qui vont manifester demain
mardi 31 janvier à juste titre
très bien
la parole est à Madame Garin mais oui
oui vous cherchez c'est pour ça je vous
vois pas d'ici
merci Madame la
comme ça a été dit si vous nous proposez
de supprimer certains régimes spéciaux
on sait pas trop pourquoi lesquels
on voit aussi que la ficelle est
un seul madame Gaara à la parole
toujours très délicat
tout ça pour dire que
vous m'avez déconcentré la ficelle est
un peu grosse puisque ici vous nous
proposez en appliquant la clause du
grand père que les salariés déjà en
poste conservent le régime spécial donc
peut-être que vous espérez qu'il y aura
moins de monde demain dans la rue le 31
mais je crois que ça ne fonctionnera pas
parce que tout le monde il y a une
solidarité dans ce pays qui s'est
révélée déjà le 19 janvier il sera
encore présente demain et je crois qu'il
est bon de rappeler comme on dit mes
collègues que les régimes spéciaux ils
ont été justifiés par des contraintes
particulières je pense aux horaires de
nuit je pense aux astreintes et ils sont
souvent nécessaires pour valoriser des
secteurs où il est compliqué d'attirer
de nouveaux salariés moi je pense au
secteur des transports par exemple
aujourd'hui à Lyon par exemple on a du
mal à recruter nos chauffeurs de bus et
à l'heure de la crise écologique alors
on veut déployer l'offre de transport en
commun on trouve pas de main d'oeuvre
pour ça donc les régimes spéciaux on
leur utilité et s'il doit y avoir un
alignement cette alignement il doit se
faire par le haut et il doit être
concerté avec l'ensemble des salariés
concernés
très bien donc je vais passer à présent
la parole à Madame la rapporteur pour
nous donner son avis sur ses amendements
de suppression oui merci Madame merci
madame la Présidente la justification de
la suppression des régimes spéciaux elle
est triple elle est d'abord une question
de justice
la raison de ces régimes la raison
d'être de ces régimes tient soit de
conditions historiques soit de
conditions particulières de pénibilité
mais ces conditions sont pour certains
plus réunis aujourd'hui pour d'autres
métiers pénibles sont eux dans le régime
général donc c'est une premièrement une
question de justice deuxièmement c'est
une question de simplicité et de
lisibilité
l'existence de ces régimes spéciaux
contribue contribuent à la complexité de
notre paysage des retraites dans le pays
58% des personnes qui sont affiliées
assez régimes sont polypensionnés
et enfin c'est une mesure d'équité entre
régime alors qu'un régime comme celui de
la RATP n'est financé qu'à hauteur de
40% par les cotisations versées par les
salariés et l'employeur et 60% par une
dotation de l'État je rappelle cependant
que nous maintenons la filiation à
l'assurance vieillesse de ces régimes
aux personnes qui sont déjà affiliés par
la fameuse clause du grand-père donc
c'est un avis défavorable surtout ses
amendements très bien Madame la
rapporteur alors j'ai plusieurs demandes
d'intervention de groupe monsieur Jubin
vous avez la parole merci madame la
Présidente
oui une des justifications la
rapporteuse vient de l'expliquer c'est
c'est qu'un certain c'est que ces
régimes spéciaux sont très souvent
déficit mais il y a quand même un point
qui est formidable pourquoi voulez-vous
supprimer le régime spécial de la Banque
de France c'est un régime par
capitalisation qui est à l'équilibre qui
est même en excédent et qui permet par
ces excédents également de faire des
versements budget d'État c'est quand
même très étonnant pour une fois que
quelque chose
en France et bien on décide de le
supprimer alors peut-être est-ce là la
volonté de l'État simplement de faire
des des fonds de tiroirs et de piquer
l'argent là où il existe moi je trouve
que le fond est bien géré encore une
fois il remplit sa mission et j'ai je ne
comprends pas cette volonté de l'État à
moins que ça soit faire les poches
effectivement comme le dit Monsieur
Bazin de la suppression de ce régime
c'est incompréhensible
très bien monsieur de Courson vous avez
la parole
oui mes chers collègues
je voudrais rappeler que le programme du
CNR en 1944
prévoyait l'unification de ces régimes
et que suite à des débats passionnants
pour ceux qui ont lu les débats de 46 47
ils ont renoncé
et c'est plus compliqué que ça c'est
grâce au MRP et à la droite qu'on a
maintenu les régimes spéciaux
mais oui mais oui mais oui moi j'ai relu
j'ai relu tous les débats c'est c'est
un petit point d'histoire seul monsieur
le député j'ai plusieurs questions à
poser à madame le rapporteur
expliquez-nous pourquoi
vous supprimez vous mettez en extinction
pour être précis 5 régimes et pas les 9
autres il y en a 14
expliquez-nous pourquoi
et pourquoi en particulier vous mettez
en extinction le régime des élus du CESU
enfin des membres du CE pour être précis
mais pas celui de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Sénat
des députés et des sénateurs et nos
objectifs pas un argument qui ne tient
pas qui est que ceci n'est pas de la
compétence de la loi je vous rappelle
que ce sont deux résolutions une du
Sénat de 1904 et de l'assemblée de la
Chambre des députés à l'époque de 1902
qui a créé un régime de retraite qui
n'existait pas jusqu'au début du 20e
siècle mes chers collègues et donc on
peut parfaitement légiférer là-dessus
donc pourquoi et dernier point quid du
financement de ces régimes en extinction
puisque dans l'exposé des motifs on nous
explique qu'on va voir plus tard comment
on va faire
dans l'exposition cette mesure
nécessitera à terme de revoir le circuit
financier du financement de ce régime
des travaux seront conduits en ce sens
en 2023 dans le perspective du projet de
loi de financement social de 2024 est-ce
que vous pourriez nous éclairer
là-dessus moi à titre personnel
j'ai toujours défendu la mise en
extinction de tous les régimes spéciaux
mais pas de quatre ou cinq d'entre eux
merci madame la Présidente donc
effectivement on traite de la fermeture
de plusieurs régimes spéciaux régis par
le domaine réglementaire on aura donc
peu de leviers d'intervention sinon
direct sinon des préservé simplement
juste avant d'entrer dans le cœur du
sujet je voudrais attirer l'attention de
mes collègues sur le fait que ces
régimes prennent évidemment une place
considérable dans le débat public
représente 2% des dépenses de retraite
ils sont quand même loin de constituer
le cœur du sujet véritable qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui nous nous
accorderons peut-être tous ici à dire
que le nombre de régimes spéciaux ne se
justifie plus qu'il correspondent
parfois des enjeux obsolètes qui
convient même de les fermer si vous
arrivez à être mesuré mes chers
collègues de gauche on va y arriver ceci
dit tout est permis aujourd'hui j'ai
quand même entendu Louis Boyard par les
d'ores et disciplines donc je pense que
tout peut arriver
aussi la fermeture du régime spécial de
la Banque de France par exemple ne nous
sent pas dénué de sens encore celui du
CESU comité Théodule on le sait qui sert
moins a priori à servir les intérêts
économiques du pays s'est passé les
quelques copains du pouvoir en place
j'attire pourtant l'attention de la
commission aussi sur ces discours
culpabilisants et parfois outrancier qui
concerne les régimes spéciaux vous vous
en doutez nos objectifs de justice
sociale ne passeront pas par
l'abaissement des seuils de tous on
entend quand même cette petite musique
qu'on entend trop souvent qui pointe du
doigt certains Français certaines
professions cette musique nous paraît
injuste au nombre de salariés qui
connaissent des difficultés notables et
qui savent qu'évidemment si nous voulons
maintenir leur mission il faut parfois
apporter un élément social attractif
alors oui nous nous assumons que
certains métiers d'intérêt d'utilité
publique puissent bénéficier davantage
en termes de retraites alors il se
justifie parfois simplement par la
faisabilité même pratique j'allais dire
de ces métiers et a priori personne ici
ne ferait monter ses enfants dans un bus
se conduit par un chauffeur de 66 ans je
ne note par ailleurs que la disparition
du régime des marins et des marins
pêcheurs envisagés par le gouvernement
en 2020 n'est plus d'actualité alors
nous nous en réjouissons c'est peut-être
là le signe d'un retour à la maison et
de bonne augures pour d'autres régimes
dont le maintien sera aussi pertinent
aussi vous le verrez
nous avons choisi de défendre le régime
de RATP des clercs et des employés de
notaire
merci madame la Présidente je
commencerai juste entendre dans notre
belle commission que le CESU est un
comité Théodule vont me permettre d'être
d'être relativement choqué surtout dans
cette commission j'entends des collègues
être
abasourdi alors j'entends on n'est pas
dans un comité syndical nous sommes des
députés alors avant d'être député nous
sommes des citoyens parfois même des
citoyens syndiqués donc oui nous avons
le droit de parler de la mobilisation de
demain le 31 janvier que ça vous plaise
ou non
et ben oui parce que avant nous restons
des citoyens comme tout le monde nous
parlons en parlant de régime spéciaux de
pénibilité au travail et je me rappelle
et je sais que c'est dur pour vous
monsieur Macron ne veut pas entendre
parler de pénibilité au travail parce
que ça voudrait sous-entendre que le
travail puisse être pénible j'avais
d'ailleurs supprimé le 5 critères de
pénibilité au travail
chers collègues le travail peut être
pénible et c'est pour ça que il y a des
régimes spéciaux qui existent les
troubles musculoosquelettiques existent
certains de nos collègues souffrent et
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont des régimes
spéciaux les collègues de la menant mais
évidemment mais écoutez chers collègues
vous allez aller conduire
comment un TER un métro vous allez faire
agent EDF aussi un petit peu et puis au
bout de 15 jours 3 semaines on discutera
un petit peu de l'état de votre
squelette et puis après vous viendrez me
voir et puis vous me direz si le régime
spécial vaut le coup ou pas après il y a
un moment donné il y a des réalités et
les réalités de la vie sont que le corps
suit ou suit pas et c'est peut-être pour
ça que des choses ont été créées donc
c'est pour ça que nous voterons aider
demain pour ceux qui peuvent encore les
lever
ben non parce que je suis bloqué c'est
pour ça que je le dis
les troubles musculoosquelettiques chers
collègues
la parole est à Madame taillée Pollion
merci madame la Présidente alors
je dirais bien tenté bien tenter d'avoir
posé en article premier d'un projet de
loi de finance rectificatif un une
disposition qui en fait ne n'apporte
aucun élément pour l'équilibre financier
puisque c'est reporté à plus tard
alors je me suis dit mais pourquoi mais
pourquoi font-ils ça pourquoi met-il
comme ça au tout début ces régimes
spéciaux alors que bah finalement c'est
pas du tout le cœur du de leur de leur
sujet puisque le sujet c'est l'équilibre
financier alors peut-être ce serait pour
monter les salariés les uns contre les
autres ah oui effectivement et dire que
la justice sociale ce serait finalement
de ben finalement de prendre de prendre
aux salariés modestes pour pour ne rien
donner aux salariés encore plus modestes
en fait de monter les gens les uns
contre les autres alors je crois que on
peut supprimer cet article puisque ça
n'a pas marché et que le 31 janvier et
bien régimes spéciaux et régime général
seront côte à côte dans la rue pour
manifester
très bien la parole est à Madame
Parmentier le coq
oui merci madame la Présidente
avant d'entrer vraiment sur le sujet je
voudrais vraiment condamné les propos
scandaleux de Madame Lafayette sur le
CSO c'est un irspect total je pense pour
nous institutions républicaines et
surtout pour une instance qui permet la
représentation de la société civile et
qui a un élément fondateur et important
de notre de notre démocratie
le régime spéciaux je pense que ne se
justifie plus totalement aujourd'hui
pour les exemples qu'on peut être évoqué
tout à l'heure je pense l'exemple des
chauffeurs de bus de la RATP qui
aujourd'hui peuvent partir à 56 ans
quand d'autres dans d'autres villes ils
partent à 62 ans donc comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait justifier les différences
aussi importantes comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait justifier également que la
Banque de France sur laquelle je crois
pas qu'il y ait une pénibilité
particulière puisse maintenir également
un régime spécial donc je crois que
comme l'a dit même la rapporteur c'est
un effort de lisibilité c'est un effort
de clarté aussi et de finance publique
puisque ce sont des des régimes pour la
plupart qui sont particulièrement
coûteux et donc il est justifié de les
réintégrer dans le régime général comme
c'est prévu par le texte dans lequel
sont prévues évidemment des dispositions
pour prendre en compte la pénibilité
puis je souhaitais ajouter que nous ne
supprimons pas les régimes spéciaux
puisque nous maintenant celui démarre un
pêcheur dont bien évidemment la
pénibilité et
la difficulté n'est pas approuvée et
enfin je souhaitais même la présidente
rappeler que nous demandons un effort
vous français mais rappelez que les
députés bénéficiaient d'un régime
spécial de retraite également et que
nous avons nous les députés de la
majorité supprimer ce régime spécial dès
2017 donc nous appliquons aussi à
nous-mêmes des règles que nous demandons
aussi à des efforts que nous demandons
en français très bien Madame la Députée
la parole est à Monsieur Daredevil
merci madame la Présidente
d'abord je pense qu'il faut lever un
certain nombre de fantasmes qui ont été
alimentés de depuis des années autour
des régimes d'IS spéciaux qui sont des
régimes effectivement pionniers qui ont
inventé un certain nombre de droits qui
d'ailleurs se retrouve aussi nécessaire
dans le dans le régime général il
représente 1,4% de la population active
et 4 % de l'ensemble des retraités je
crois que c'est toujours bien de
regarder précisément de quoi on parle et
évidemment une sont pas responsables des
difficultés financières sur lesquelles
nous allons discuter
qui pourrait voir le jour dans le dans
le régime général ça n'est évidemment
pas le sujet d'autant que au moins deux
d'entre ceux que vous voulez supprimer
contribue à par la solidarité au régime
général c'est le cas du régime de la
Banque de France et de celui des
industries électriques et gaziens donc
on voit bien qu'on est là dans une
mesure qui est essentiellement d'ordre
symbolique elle n'aura pas d'effet pour
2023 donc d'ailleurs c'est un article
qui recevable puisque il s'agit d'une
loi de finance rectificative pour 2023
donc on voit bien qu'on est dans tout à
fait autre chose que ce qui nous est
annoncé avec cet article là par contre
ça va provoquer à terme une dégradation
brutale pour les nouveaux entrants des
droits et puis vous qui vendez les
négociations de branches et que sais-je
encore vous ici vous asseyez largement
dessus puisqu'il s'agit effectivement de
discussion qui ont eu lieu dans cette
branche et qui ont permis d'établir des
droits correspondant d'ailleurs à au
travail effectué aux conditions de
travail qui qui ont été constatées dans
dans ces régimes et donc je crois que
nous devons effectivement parler du
travail ici vous n'en parlez pas vous
supprimer d'un trait de plume des
régimes qui cherchent à prendre en
compte la pénibilité puisque ça a été
sans doute un de leurs une de leurs
vertus principales donc voilà nous
sommes opposés à cette manière de
fonctionner qui veut en permanence tirer
tout vers le bas qui nous entraîne dans
une spirale de dumping social alors que
nous devrions au contraire essayer de
regarder comment améliorer la situation
que celles et ceux dans les droits sont
trop faibles
oui merci madame la Présidente je crois
que la notion de régime spécial et
profondément antagoniste du régime par
répartition puisque c'est les actifs
d'aujourd'hui qui payent pour les
pensionnés d'aujourd'hui et quand
aujourd'hui on a des métiers qui
naissent tous les jours d'autres métiers
qui disparaissent d'autres métiers dont
la démographie évolue et bien ces
régimes certains certes sont en
excédents et d'autres sont en déficit et
il faut que ça soit la puissance
publique qui les équilibre que les
salariés dans leur ensemble soient
établi au même règle soit soumis au même
règle par du bon sens les règles de
pénibilité je les ai entendu elles
doivent être généralisées à tous ceux
qui les côtoient au cours de leur
carrière et aujourd'hui force est de
constater que ce cette division en
régime différent pose problème à ceux
qui changent de métier au cours de leur
vie de façon choisie ou de façon subie
avec des règles qui sont totalement
abscons puisque elles ne sont pas
cohérentes les unes avec les autres donc
je crois que c'est ça fait partie du bon
sens on a entendu le fait que ceux qui
sont dans ces régimes là ne souhaitent
pas perdre un certain nombre de de
bénéfices ou de règles spécifiques alors
éteignant le système pour les nouveaux
entrants et ça sera la façon la plus la
plus souple et la plus légitime de
mettre fin à cette inéquité du système
très bien
donc quelques remarques Madame La
Valette vous dites que c'est de pour
cent des retraités mais c'est 6
milliards de dépenses de l'État il nous
semble important de de le prendre en
compte et cela a été dit en termes de de
justice c'est difficile à expliquer
qu'un chauffeur de bus à Paris
pourrait partir plus tôt qu'un chauffeur
de bus dans en milieu rural donc
ça nous paraît important pour répondre à
monsieur de Courson il s'agit bien de de
la nécessité de mettre dans la loi
organique les régimes des parlementaires
c'est une ordonnance de 1958 et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que les amendements
déposés sur ce sujet ont été
irrecevables
pour répondre à Nathalie et polluant les
ce texte cet article rentre bien dans le
cadre d'un PLFSS rectificatif puisque
les nouveaux salariés à partir du 1er
septembre ne pourront plus bénéficier de
ces régimes spéciaux et enfin à Monsieur
Daredevil pour
vous disiez que il y avait
négodé négociations
avec les représentations syndicales mais
typiquement là pour l'application du
départ de l'âge à 64 ans les discussions
sont en cours dans les entreprises avec
les entreprises pour ceux qui sont le je
dirais le stock
très bien sur ce je vais mettre aux voix
donc ces amendements de suppression qui
est pour
qui est contre
oui c'est bon ils sont rejetés
amendement identiques monsieur Guedj
pour le 881 monsieur le député
s'il vous plaît
oui alors après avoir posé le principe
de la suppression en bloc de l'ensemble
de ces
régimes spéciaux on va évoquer
spécifiquement certains d'entre eux en
l'occurrence ce premier amendement porte
sur le régime spécial des retraités de
la de la RATP
et moi je veux faire écho à ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure je sais plus par qui
sur les sujets de de pénibilité parce
que nous avons là spécifiquement des
régimes pour lesquels la question de la
pénibilité demeure j'entendais quelqu'un
tout à l'heure qui disait on peut
s'interroger sur la réalité je crois que
c'est vous madame la rapportrice de du
maintien de situation de pénibilité sur
un certain nombre de ces de ces régimes
écoutez faudrait que vous m'expliquez en
quoi les conducteurs et les agents
roulants de la RATP ne sont pas
concernés par la situation de de
pénibilité avec la prise en compte d'une
meilleure anticipation des départs et
une meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité vous avez donc les faire
rentrer dans le droit commun de votre
logique qui est celle de l'allongement
de l'âge légal nous en parlons des
hommes mais surtout des mesures dont
nous allons beaucoup parler qui sont
celles de prise en compte de la
pénibilité dont on verra et dont on
décortiquera qu'elles sont notoirement
insuffisantes et je vois pas comment
l'application du C2P au rouleur de la
RATP sera un progrès pour eux si il faut
aligner alors alignons sur ceux des
régimes qui réellement aujourd'hui
prennent en compte la pénibilité et pas
quand vous envisagez de le faire un
nivellement par le bas très bien
monsieur Monnet madame
oui en réalité madame la rapporteur ce
que vous appelez inéquité entre régime
général et régime spéciaux je comprends
que vous ayez envie d'utiliser ce terme
puisque en fait ça cache les attaques
répétées que le gouvernement précédent
celui d'actuellement d'autres
précédemment on fait pour attaquer
le régime général
des attaques vers le moins 10 ans social
le nivellement par le bas en permanence
qui crée effectivement maintenant un
écart entre les régimes spéciaux et le
régime général c'est le résultat de vos
politiques de cas sociales et qui ont
fait revenir sur un certain nombre
d'aquis sociaux également présents dans
dans le régime général donc nous ce que
nous vous proposons justement c'est de
prendre en compte le mieux disant social
d'aller vers la prise en compte à la
fois de la pénibilité la prendre en
compte pour compenser mais la prendre en
compte aussi pour travailler sur la
pénibilité ne pas se satisfaire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des millions et
des millions de travailleurs et de
travailleuses qui travaillent dans des
conditions inacceptables voilà pourquoi
faut les prendre en compte les critères
pour pouvoir aussi les dépasser vous
vous refusez de les voir d'ailleurs
votre gouvernement le précédent en a
supprimé 4 de critères de pénibilité
alors qu'il en faudrait plus je pense
notamment à toute la question de
psychologie du stress etc et puis vous
avez aussi supprimé les CHSCT
vous vous en fichez de la question de la
santé et de la pénibilité au travail et
vous ne voulez surtout pas l'aborder
mais oui c'est vrai est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous avez écouté pour les
agents RATP ce que c'est de faire des
horaires décalés pendant 30 ans des
services mixtes des services mixtes vous
faites les horaires de pointe du matin
et vous faites les horaires du soir dans
un moment où il y a un problème de
recrutement et où et où tout le monde
est stressé de monter dans les
transports et il y a de l'agressivité
qui monte entre usagers et entre et
entre salariés on a un défi climatique
il faut du transport il faut des agents
et à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que vous
prenez vous le fait de vous attaquer au
statut très bien
la parole est à alors attendez voir
Monsieur Clouet
non madame Simonet madame Simonet aucun
problème oui écoutez cette volonté de
supprimer le régime spéciaux et
notamment celui de la RATP on sait
d'abord que c'est une c'est d'abord une
stratégie diversion pour essayer de
masquer le cœur de votre trade qui est
de voler deux ans de vie deux ans de
retraite deux envies après labeur 2 ans
de bonheur mais c'est aussi une
stratégie de division et au nom alors du
chauffeur de bus de zone rurales il
faudrait supprimer et bien les régimes
spéciaux à l'arrêté et qu'elle cynisme
en fait que votre conception de
l'égalité puisqu'à chaque fois c'est
nivellement par le bas pourquoi ne pas
proposer justement ce régime spécial
pour l'ensemble des chauffeurs de bus il
y a un mépris complet de la pénibilité
et vous allez ajouter une pénibilité
administrative à la pénibilité au
travail moi j'aimerais bien vous inviter
pas simplement à la manifestation du
demain que tout le monde a déjà cité
mais venez au piquet de grève demain à
la station alors au dépôt de bus Lagny
RA dans le 20ème vous rencontrerez
Nathalie et pourquoi est-ce que Nathalie
fait grève alors qu'elle partira à la
retraite dans quelques mois parce que
justement elle a subi les horaires
décalés elle était puisée de toute une
vie de travail quand on enquille à 4h30
du matin et qu'on enchaîne parfois dans
les dans les dans les emplois du temps
mixte des horaires le soir que les
weekends sont pris au travail oui c'est
une pénibilité terrible ce qu'il
faudrait à mes chers collègues c'est au
contraire non pas supprimer les régimes
spéciaux mais créer de nouveaux régimes
spéciaux pour prendre en compte par
ailleurs d'autres pénibilité comme la
pénibilité et bien de ces caissières que
moi j'ai rencontré vendredi qui faisait
grève aussi contre la réforme des
retraites parce que elle les actes
totalement répétitifs qui ne sont pas
prises en compte qui créent des troubles
musculo-squelettiques très bien Madame
la député la parole est à Monsieur
Ruffin
c'est Christophe Bex
alors les régimes pionniers sont le
fruit de notre histoire sociale et à
votre habitude vous cherchez à la
saborder depuis des années à l'image de
vos prédécesseurs vous entonnez le même
refrain ces régimes idéaux sont coûteux
et mettraient ainsi à mal l'équilibre
financier du système
en réalité ces derniers ne représentent
que 3,5% de l'ensemble des cotisants en
France avec votre contre-réforme vous
souhaitez supprimer parmi tant d'autres
le régime idéal des agents de la RATP
vous répétez à qui veut bien l'entendre
que l'existence du régime idéal de RATP
n'apparaît plus justifié regarde des
principes d'équité et d'universalité
mais chers collègues
qu'y a-t-il de juste et équitable à
faire travailler plus longtemps des
salariés qui souffrent déjà d'une
espérance de vie inférieure à la moyenne
des Français qu'y a-t-il de juste et
équitable à faire travailler plus
longtemps des salariés qui pâtissent de
conditions de travail difficile et
toujours plus dégradée qu'y a-t-il de
juste et équitable univelé vers le bas
les modalités de calcul des pensions de
retraite aboutissant ainsi une
diminution de celle-ci qui a-t-il de
juste équitable à supprimer purement et
simplement les dispositifs qui
permettent un départ anticipé à la
retraite instaurer initialement pour
compenser la pénibilité de ces métiers
la notion d'équité vous semble
visiblement étrangère
réformé le système des retraites vers
une plus grande équité nécessiterait à
l'inverse d'appliquer ces mesures
compensatrices à l'ensemble des branches
et des régimes au sein desquels les
salariés pâtissent de conditions de
travail dégradées
très bien la parole est à Madame kéké
merci madame la Présidente passe
notamment nous souhaitons que le régime
spécial de la Régie autonome des
transports parisiens RATP dit maintenu
la RATP est un acteur vital pour toute
la région l'Île-de-France elle assure
tous ses services 24 sur 24 7 jours sur
7 même les weekends et les jours fériés
et de fait sans interruption savez-vous
combien d'employés sont mobilisés chaque
jour pour que chaque pour que les
travailleurs de l'Île-de-France se
déplacent tous les jours et toutes les
heures au travail et dans les services
par métro bus tramway RATP RER combien
se mobilise pour qu'on vienne nous-mêmes
ici à l'Assemblée nationale des
centaines combien d'entre vous qui sont
pour la suppression du régime spécial de
la RATP ce sont déjà intéressés à la
pénibilité liée à la maintenance du
réseau
au travail de nuit aux conditions de
travail nous avons le choix et la
possibilité d'empêcher la suppression de
ce régime beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs
n'ont pas été touchés faisons la même
chose
très bien la parole est à Madame La
Valette
c'est monsieur
le Président c'est l'abonnement vise à
supprimer les dispositions prévues dans
le code de la sécurité sociale
instaurant une clause du grand-père en
vue de la fermeture du régime spécial de
la Régie autonome des transports
parisiens les prêts de 70 000 salariés
de la RATP et les 11 millions
d'habitants de la région parisienne
connaissent une situation sociale et
fonctionnelle inédite rendant la vie
infernale pour ceux qui travaillent et
autant pour les usagers à l'heure des
grands discours sur les métiers en
tension il est important de relever que
ces difficultés d'exploitation sont
notamment le fait de discuter de
recrutement comme l'autoly et la
restauration le transport de personnes
connaît un besoin sans précédent de
nouvelles recrues au profil
particulièrement varié du non diplômé au
Bac+5 dans ce contexte d'abaissement des
droits et atrés sociaux de ces missions
nous semblent être une erreur non
seulement pour la régie mais avant tout
pour les usagers qui auront déjà subir
des désagréments jusqu'à l'été pour les
franciliens et pour l'activité
économique de la première région
française ainsi nous vous demandons de
maintenir ce régime et à plus on nos
collègues les républicains proche de la
majorité régionale à en faire de même je
vous remercie
très bien Madame non il y a quelqu'un
encore madame sebahi ce sera madame
taille et polliant merci madame la
Présidente oui concernant le régime
spécial de la RATP je pense que toutes
les personnes qui prennent les
transports en commun dans la métropole
du Grand Paris ça va à quel point la
situation est dégradée
et que on a un problème de recrutement
donc là commencez par dire qu'on va
baisser
on va tirer vers le bas les conditions
sociales de d'emploi c'est complètement
irresponsable parce que c'est encore une
fois mettre les gens en difficulté pour
trouver des conducteurs de bus etc etc
et assurer un niveau de service
relativement acceptable donc c'est
totalement irresponsable par ailleurs
sur la santé au travail vous savez il y
a un grand institut national l'INRS
institut national de recherche sur la
sécurité qui s'occupe de santé au
travail
ils disent quoi ils disent le risque de
troubles musculo-squelettiques chez les
chauffeurs de bus de points une réalité
cette monographie étudie le risque de
troubles musculoosquelettiques chez les
chauffeurs de bus elle concerne
principalement les chauffeurs de bus
intra-urbain dont typiquement la RATP
les TMS du rachis chez les chauffeurs de
bus résultent d'une combinaison de
facteurs de risque biomécanique
chronique et aiguë auquel s'ajoutent des
facteurs psychosociaux et la conception
de leur poste de conduite donc
pénibilité il y a régime spécial doit
être maintenu
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis sur ses amendements oui merci
madame la Présidente on débat de la
pénibilité mais la fin de régime
spéciaux ne veut pas dire que nous ne
prenons pas en compte la pénibilité ce
que nous disons ce que nous disons et
Madame Tallier polluant vous venez vous
venez de parler des chauffeurs
intra-muros qui ont des troubles
musculo-squelettiques c'est vrai à Paris
mais c'est vrai aussi à Lille à Bordeaux
à Toulouse et donc la pénibilité doit
être prise en compte mais c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça c'est d'ailleurs pour
son écoute madame la rapporteur s'il
vous plaît c'est justement parce que
nous voulons
améliorer la prise en compte de cette
pénibilité nous aurons l'occasion je
l'espère dans débattre à l'article 9 que
nous augmentons par exemple pour ces
chauffeurs de RATP le nombre de points
du C2P du compte de prévention pour le
travail de nuit pour les équipes
alternantes donc le débat de la
pénibilité moi je l'entends tout à fait
et nous avons des mesures dans ce texte
pour améliorer l'usure professionnelle
enfin la prise en compte de l'usure
professionnelle et de la pénibilité mais
c'est pas le sujet du régime spécial en
fait
d'autre part alors c'est une remarque
plus
légistique mais la façon dont sont
écrits tous les amendements là qui
arrivent sur ce sujet et qui sont écrits
d'une façon qui fait que vous affiliez
toutes les personnes au régime général
et je comprends bien que c'est pas votre
votre attention donc pour ça je pense
qu'il faut les retirer mais dans tous
les cas sur le fond c'est un avis
défavorable
très bien donc j'ai plusieurs demandes
de paroles je commence tout de suite par
Monsieur Vigier
merci la présidente
mes chers collègues
je rappelle il y a un petit ouvrage que
je conseille à chacun et un petit
ouvrage qui raconte toute l'histoire des
régimes spéciaux nés sous l'Ancien
Régime explique les conditions dans
lesquelles ils ont été établies
j'entends bien votre supplique pour nous
dire qu'il faut absolument préserver la
RATP
je voudrais juste dire trois choses
d'abord est-ce que c'est fait de façon
brutale non puisque je rappelle qu'il y
a la clause du grand-père et la clause
du grand-père chacun la connaît
mais la brutalité la brutalité chère
collègues ça serait de dire que du jour
au lendemain et bien touchant pour que
rien ne change
c'est bien mais la brutalité ça serait
de dire c'est terminé il y a plus
d'origine spéciale la clause du
grand-père ça veut dire quoi c'est
honoré la signature du contrat initial
puisque à la fin de la carrière et bien
les avantages qui étaient donnés
resteront la deuxième chose j'aurais
personne n'a dit mot sur le fait c'était
quand même un peu ébauché c'est vrai que
ce sont des difficultés pour travailler
pour ces chauffeurs RATP que nous
n'ayons pas
mais il y a d'autres villes et d'autres
agglomérations moi je pense Nicolas
sangsue à Vierzon par exemple est-ce
qu'il est normal que les chauffeurs de
l'agglomération de Vierzon ou celle de
Bourges eux travaillent jusqu'à 62 ans
ou 64 ans et j'ai pas vu et je n'ai pas
vu chers collègues s'il vous plaît et je
n'ai pas vu cher collègue dans des
villes de gauche dites très fortes pour
faire en sorte que vous chauffeurs et
vos conducteurs de bus ou de métro
partent à 56 ans comme elle RATP alors
c'est toujours bien dirigé des
propositions et donner des leçons mais
il faut toujours être en phase avec ce
que l'on propose la troisième chose sur
la pénibilité c'est peut-être un sujet
sur lequel on se retrouvera
parce que la somme des critères et on
voit la
établi comme elle a été établie avec des
critères dont on voit bien certains ont
été enlevé c'était peut-être pas la
meilleure des décisions non c'est pas ça
pour moi la pénibilité la vraie Pise
encore de la pénibilité c'est quoi c'est
qu'à un moment ou un autre on
reconnaisse que pour ces personnes qui
sont particulièrement exposées et bien
on soit capable peut-être de les faire
partir avant et d'en trouver les
conditions et donc j'imagine que vous
nous suivrez je termine madame la
Présidente lorsque nous avons déposé des
amendements un peu plus loin pour parler
d'évolution professionnelle juste à la
nupaisse qui devrait être intéressé
évolution professionnelle de 45 ans et
60 ans pour où on en est justement dans
les carrières la parole est à monsieur
de Courson j'aimerais bien un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît cher collègue
oui mes chers collègues c'était Linéa il
pose le problème de l'égalité des
Français devant la retraite
je vous rappelle que quand on a réformé
le statut de la SNCF on a mis en
extinction le régime de retraite de la
SNCF
et donc vous avez sur le grand réseau
parisien la RATP et le réseau banlieue
SNCF c'est à dire que les mêmes
personnes qui font les mêmes travaux qui
ont les mêmes postes de travail sont
traités différemment donc dire qu'on met
en extinction de régime RATP c'est
cohérent avec ce qui avait été fait pour
la réforme de la SNCF deuxième
observation le problème Paris province
pourquoi la les mêmes agents qui en
province sont au régime général et qui
ont les mêmes postes que ceux au sein de
la RATP sont traités d'une façon
différente donc c'est tout à fait
cohérent de ce point de vue là de mettre
en extinction le régime de la RATP de
retraite
très bien la parole est à Madame
panotion Bouvet
merci madame la Présidente on voit bien
que parler de la réforme des retraites
et des futurs retraites c'est parler du
travail aujourd'hui ici et maintenant et
en particulier des conditions de travail
et c'est vrai que en ce qui concerne les
conditions de travail je pense notamment
à l'accident du travail aux accidents
mortels du travail il faut quand même
rappeler aussi ici que la France a un
des records en Europe et que alors qu'on
a on est plus on a moins d'industries
qu'en Allemagne on a plus paradoxalement
d'accidents du travail parce que ces
sujets ont été mal appréhendés depuis
des décennies lui égard aussi à la
transformation de nos tissus économiques
on s'imagine encore que les accidents du
travail c'est dans les grandes usines
mais c'est aussi dans les services les
charis dont Monsieur Ruffin a pu parler
les chauffeurs les aides-soignantes les
caissières et donc ça c'est une vraie
réalité qu'il faut pouvoir appréhender
je pense qu'il faut aussi reconnaître
deux choses sur la question des
chauffeurs RATP d'abord que c'est la
clause du grand-père donc ça va se faire
non pas dans cette brutalité telle
qu'elle a été annoncée il faut aussi lui
dire qu'il y a des vrais avancées dans
ce texte sur la prise en compte de la
pénibilité il faut quand même se dire
que au précédemment la collectivité
nationale investissait 40 millions
d'euros chaque année sur la prévention
et la santé au travail ça va passer à
200 millions chaque année la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il y aura une visite pour
les pour les métiers présumés pénibles
dont cela une visite à 45 ans et je
pense que il faut effectivement
l'enrichir pas simplement d'une visite
médicale mais d'une visite aussi
professionnel pour parler de la
compétence et des orientations parce que
c'est clair qu'on peut pas travailler de
la même manière à 40 ans ou à 60 ans et
enfin il y a des évolutions sur le
compte de pénibilité comme l'a dit
Madame la rapporteur sur la
multi-exposition qui permet de corriger
certaines inégalités donc saluons les
prises en compte sur la pénibilité et ne
disons pas que l'extinction des régimes
spéciaux est très progressive ne se fait
pas dans la prise en compte de la
réalité de la pénibilité sur lequel il y
a encore beaucoup beaucoup à faire en
tant que pays merci très bien bien la
parole est à Monsieur de la porte merci
madame la Présidente on est ici sur un
article qui est symbolique de la
philosophie de votre réforme quand
certains ont quelques droits en plus qui
sont nécessaires nécessités par une
situation particulière vous préférez
leur dire non vous n'avez pas le droit
en plus on préfère que vous ayez des
droits en moins pour peut-être donner à
certains quelques droits tout en
repoussant leur âge légal de départ à la
retraite nous c'est pas ça c'est pas des
droits en moins pour certains et
quelques droits en plus pour une poignée
il s'agit ici de prendre en compte un
métier spécifique est-ce que vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un agent RATP sur
5 qui finit en inaptitude
est-ce que vous avez pris le métro
peut-être comme moi ce matin pour venir
vous avez vu les quais bondés ce matin à
Saint-Lazare il a fallu que j'attende 15
minutes pour pouvoir rentrer dans le
métro
[Musique]
je vous mets à la place de l'agent qui
est là avec ce stress avec ses pieds
bondé avec cette crainte de voir
quelqu'un qui tombe sur les rails vu la
pression qu'il existe il s'est levé
peut-être à trois ou quatre heures du
matin pour commencer son service parce
que les trains évidemment il commence à
circuler tôt ils finissent tard les
agents de la RATP ils ont des suggestion
particulière ils ont par ailleurs des
difficultés à être recrutées alors vous
allez dire à ceux qui arrivent demain
bah non finalement vous vous n'aurez pas
de droit spécifique et enfin je voudrais
revenir sur les fake news qui sont
véhiculés parce que aujourd'hui les
agents de la RATP ils ont certes un
régime spécial mais ils sont ils partent
pas à la retraite à 52 ans
ou à ça quand vous avez dit 56 mais
aujourd'hui ils ont des mécanismes de
décote qui fait que déjà ce n'est que la
moitié des agents qui bénéficient de ce
régime spécial c'est ceux qui sont dans
les conditions les plus spéciales les
plus spécifiques les plus difficiles et
aujourd'hui ils ne prennent pas ils ne
bénéficient pas du régime spécial parce
que la décote impacte leur niveau de
retraite donc arrêtons de dire que ce
sont des privilégiés ce sont des
personnes qui travaillent dur et ce que
vous appelez la clause du grand-père moi
je l'appellerai plutôt la clause du bébé
parce que finalement ce n'est ni les
grands-pères ni les grands-mères qui
vont être les perdants c'est ceux qui
naissent aujourd'hui qui ne pompent les
agents de la RATP de demain
en fait là on parle d'un régime spécial
et précisément d'un régime spécial sur
des métiers dont tout le monde reconnaît
la difficulté et tout le monde reconnaît
que finalement ce régime spécial devrait
être étendu à d'autres villes et non pas
à une entreprise mais à le métier en
lui-même et qu'on devrait reconnaître la
difficulté d'être chauffeur de bus on le
reconnaît sur les troubles
musculo-squelettiques on devrait aussi
le reconnaître sur l'exposition aux
pollution précisément parce que ce sont
eux aussi qui sont le plus exposés aux
particules fines et ça fait partie des
critères de pénibilité que vous ne
reconnaissez pas mais si on a les plus
loin et bien nous pourrions aussi
regarder la situation des taxis et des
VTC dont une part sont des micros
entrepreneurs donc complètement à
l'écart de toute protection sociale et
particulièrement sur la pénibilité et
que là vous voyez on est typiquement
dans quelque chose qui est purement
idéologique où vous estimez qu'il y a
des privilèges là où au contraire il y a
la santé des personnes et la vie des
gens qui est en cause
très bien monsieur porte
merci madame la Présidente justice a
équité depuis que le gouvernement a
dévoilé sa feuille de route sur la
réforme des retraites vous n'avez que
ces mots à la bouche et vous avez encore
une fois recommencé ce matin et on
mesure à l'ombre des débats qui sont les
nôtres la réalité entre vos mots et les
actes quelle justice il y a-t-il à
supprimer le régime spécial de la RATP
alors que vous préservez celui d'autres
catégories aucune et au fil de la
lecture on mesure vos intentions en
vérité vous payez les régimes spéciaux
celui de la RATP et des industries
électriques et gazir comme vous vous
êtes payé celui de la SNCF en 2018
pourquoi un tel acharnement
il n'y a aucune mesure qui permet de le
justifier simplement et représente tout
ce que vous détestez le service public
l'intérêt général et la solidarité voilà
votre véritable motivation quelle
justice à s'attaquer à un régime qui
permet à des agents de partir plus tôt à
la retraite au regard de la pénibilité
de leur métier un mot que vous refusez
de mettre dans le débat comme l'a évoqué
ma collègue Elsa aussi cela vous
n'indite pas un mot préférant multiplier
les courbes et les tableurs Excel sans
jamais parler de la vie des gens le seul
qui m'a parlé chez vous c'est Gérald
Darmanin pour insulter les salariés qui
se mobilisent car la RATP c'est aussi
les Français qui se lèvent tôt et qui
demain seront dans la rue travailler un
horaire décalé deux jours comme de nuit
les weekends les jours fériés le stress
de la circulation la gestion des usagers
tout cela mérite largement un système de
retraite qui compense cette pénibilité
enfin cette réforme et celle de
l'injustice ça a été dit un salarié sur
5 de la RATP fini un inaptitude et
beaucoup souffrent de pathologies liées
à un métier difficile là aussi silence
radio de la majorité on comprend votre
gêne comment pourriez-vous parler de
pénibilité même que vous avez vidé le
grand pénibilité de ce contenu encore
une fois rien ne justifie cette
suppression d'origine spéciale de la
RATP si ce n'est votre mépris de classe
à la gare de ces salariés
oui merci madame la Présidente si
j'écoute monsieur Vigier ce qui nous
explique en fait c'est que si ton voisin
il a pas de pain tu en auras pas non
plus vous êtes en fait à deux doigts de
nous dire qu'il faut tous manger de la
brioche en tout cas pas loin mais
vraiment cette logique qui consiste à
expliquer que parce que une un régime
des salariés aurait des droits et que
d'autres n'en n'ont pas ou en tout cas
moindre il faudrait supprimer ce qu'on
des droits mais vous vous rendez compte
dans quelle société vous nous emmenez et
c'est bien celle-là avec ce projet de
recul de l'âge départ à la retraite un
glissement un glissement vers la
négation de la conquête de droit c'est
exactement là que vous souhaitez nous
emmener la vérité c'est que vous voulez
surtout pas qu'on parle de pénibilité
parce que la pénibilité ça pousse à de
la compensation et donc à de la
solidarité et ça c'est des termes que
nous voulons absolument pas entendre pas
la peine de nous expliquer que c'est le
C2P qui va permettre de compenser ça
tout le monde sait ici que ça ne
fonctionne pas que ça ne marche pas que
vous-même vous avez aussi supprimé tout
dispositif de retraite anticipée donc ça
ne sera pas possible non plus pour ces
agents dont vous entendez supprimer le
régime général vous essayez au-delà de
les faire passer pour des privilégiés
vous faites vous souhaitez les faire
passer aussi pour des profiteurs mais
rappelons quand même qu'ils sur cotise
ces agents pour leur régime leur régime
spéciaux il surcotise ils ne sont à eux
vous voulez leur enlever les droits
acquis par cette surcotisation c'est
quand même bizarre parce que des
profiteurs on en a vu ces dernières
années on en voit en ce moment des
profiteurs de crise et à eux il faudra
en permanence les discours gentils pour
leur expliquer pour leur expliquer qu'il
faut qu'il donne un peu plus on vous
avait proposé la taxation des super
profits on va continuer
Madame La Valette vous avez la parole
madame la Présidente merci alors madame
est vous dites la pénibilité la même
dans les grandes villes ça n'est pas
tout à fait vrai je vous rappelle que il
y a des grandes villes qui ont pas de
métro pas de RER et donc pas de salariés
en souterrain aussi vous répondez pas à
cette histoire de pénibilité dans ces
métiers ou les conducteurs passent des
décennies sous terre jour et nuit
monsieur Vigier à verzio à Vierzon
pardon il n'y a pas la ligne 13 alors si
vous voulez nous pouvons aller la
prendre en sortant vous verrez ce qu'il
en est concrètement si elle est
surnommée la ligne de l'enfer pour les
usagers elle est aussi figurez-vous pour
les salariés de la de la RATP il n'y a
pas non plus de ligne 1 comme à Toulon
où les jeunes des cités s'accrochent au
bus imaginez le stress de ses chauffeurs
et d'ailleurs comme par hasard c'est la
ligne 1 ou les chauffeurs partent le
plus en dépression alors permettez-moi
également aussi de vous dire que nous ne
faisons pas confiance à ce gouvernement
qui a supprimé en 2017 quatre des 10
critères du compte de pénibilité aussi
bien évidemment nous maintenons les
amendements qui lisent à contraintes le
gouvernement de maintenir le régime de
la RATP
au moins un moyen terme merci très bien
mes chers collègues donc nous allons
passer au vote je mets aux voix donc
tous ces amendements
identiques qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
très bien qui est qui est contre
[Musique]
très bien ils sont rejetés mes chers
collègues nous en arrivons à plusieurs
amendements pouvant être mis en
discussion commune et je passe la parole
pour le 802 à Monsieur Guedj
oui madame la Présidente je rassure tout
de suite l'ensemble de mes collègues il
y a 23 amendements et je vous propose de
prendre quelques instants pour les
présenter tous collectivants et ce
faisant avoir une discussion parce que
l'objectif de ces amendements il est
évidemment pas de provoquer une
obstruction mais d'attirer l'attention
sur le caractère évidemment arbitraire
de la décision que vous prenez vous
proposez la fin des régimes spéciaux au
premier septembre 2023 nous proposons de
l'étaler sur un temps plus long pour oui
30 ans pour justement absorber celle des
difficultés que les agents de la RATP
vivent parce que voyez-vous on sait
depuis tout à l'heure poser la question
de savoir c'était quoi le fond de la
justification et les arguments vous avez
mis en avant sont un peu
filandreux notamment sur la question
relative à la pénibilité puisque vous
nous dites nous ne contestons pas la
distance de la pénibilité pour les
agents les conducteurs de bus ou de tram
ou de métro de la RATP mais regardez
c'est formidable ils vont rentrer dans
le droit commun du C2P dont on ne sait
pas par ailleurs la réalité de la
compensation de la pénibilité qui pourra
être prise en compte alors il faut
chercher ailleurs il faut chercher
ailleurs les explications et donc on y a
pas encore fait référence mais vous avez
eu allez comment dire la délicatesse la
gentillesse la bienveillance de nous
transmettre non pas une étude d'impact
mais un rapport cherchant à analyser les
conséquences de la réforme et en lisant
attentivement celui-ci on comprend une
partie de l'arrière-pensée de votre
réforme parce que quand vous parlez des
régimes spéciaux et singulièrement de
ceux des transports vous nous expliquez
je cite que le financement des régimes
spéciaux essentiellement public implique
un effort de la solidarité nationale au
bénéfice de certains secteurs ou de
certaines entreprises
et cet effort doit être interrogé dans
le contexte de rationalisation de la
dépense publique et je cite d'ouverture
à la concurrence il s'avère que le cœur
des difficultés qui frappent aujourd'hui
la RATP et c'est l'élu francilien que je
suis qui vous le dit et comme près de
250 autres parlementaires conseillés
départementaux conseils régionaux maire
d'Île-de-France nous interpellons nous
alertons sur les difficultés que cette
ouverture à la concurrence va générer
sur
l'aération la RATP je vous rappelle
c'est 2025 pour les bus c'est 2029 pour
les tram c'est 2039 pour le RER et tout
le monde sait aujourd'hui que
l'application bête est méchante de
l'ouverture à la concurrence qui résulte
elle-même de réglementation européenne
tout aussi bête et méchante n'est pas
adaptée à la situation des transports en
Île-de-France n'est pas adapté à la
logique d'un lotissement qui doit être
mise en place et donc au moment où nous
avons des difficultés de recrutement
massif aujourd'hui des lignes de bus
c'est plus de 700 chauffeurs qu'on
n'arrive pas à recruter et ça explique
notamment que le plan bus en banlieue ne
puisse pas être mis en place avec les
promesses de Valérie Pécresse de sa
révolution des transports et fait pschit
largement cheat parce que dans le même
temps on dit qu'on va améliorer l'offre
de transport mais de l'autre côté on
impose aux opérateurs une réduction de
leur de leurs moyens et des difficultés
de recrutement et donc pour expliquer le
sens de ces amendements pour décaler
dans le temps
c'est de dire que vous allez fragiliser
un réseau de transport qui est déjà à
l'os qui est déjà dans une crise avec un
retentissement et je le dis pour que
vous l'ayez présent à l'esprit c'est que
les difficultés du réseau de transport
en Île-de-France ça accroît la
pénibilité de tous les autres salariés
parce que les aides-soignantes qui
prennent les transports en commun les
professionnels sur les plateformes
logistiques quand ils sont face à un
système de transport qui à ce point
défaillant moi en Essonne
en Essonne pardon je parle fort mais je
sais pas si le micro il marche moi en
Essonne oui mais oui mais je pourrais
faire deux minutes Philippe Philippe je
pourrais je pourrais faire deux minutes
sur les 23 amendements je vais en
prendre 5 sur le total vous voyez bien
voilà je fais une seule une seule
intervention vous avez compris il vous
reste une minute alors dans ces cas-là
monsieur
pardon pardon de mettre de la passion
sur un sujet qui passionne les luves
Franciliens que je suis mais garantir
que le réseau de transport fonctionne en
tenant compte de la pénibilité de ceux
qui le font vivre c'est pas uniquement
une mesure catégoriale peut se pour ceux
qui exercent ces métiers c'est que si
nous sommes en pénurie et un problème
d'attractivité alors c'est tous ceux qui
travaillent dur c'est les premières et
les deuxième lignes ceux qui prennent
moi je viens du département de l'Essonne
le temps de trajet moyen pour l'ensemble
des habitants de ce département dans les
transports c'est une heure 43 par jour
et c'est parfois bien plus pour ceux qui
viennent le long de la Francilienne de
Brétigny pour ceux qui viennent d'Evry
qui vont traverser sur la plateforme
aéroportuaire d'Orly ou qui vont être
dans les ou deux ou deux ou de Roissy ou
dans les métiers de service sur sur la
défense et que donc vous voyez bien que
en sanctuarisant et c'est pas une mesure
de de privilégier en sanctuarisant
l'attractivité de ces métiers pour
permettre à ce que la qualité du service
public de transport soit assuré en
Île-de-France alors vous améliorez aussi
la qualité de vie au travail de
centaines de milliers de millions de
travailleurs auxquels à côté pour ceux
qui ont des difficultés dans le
transport vous allez péniblement leur
octroyer le C2P dont je le rappelle il
ne prend pas en compte les difficultés
liées au transport parce qu'il y a une
pénibilité avec des transports qui sont
défaillants et donc si vous voulez être
à l'avant-garde de la prise en compte de
la pénibilité sanctuariser le régime de
la RATP c'est le sens de ces amendements
allez on va dire d'appel vous avez
refusé les environnement de suppression
et bah là ne vous proposons d'étaler
dans le temps de voir comment on absorbe
et dernier argument sur cette ouverture
à la concurrence puisque ces
manifestement une des sujets que vous
avez dans le fond de l'air même Clément
baume le ministre des Transports
aujourd'hui se pose la question de
savoir si c'est pertinent alors bien sûr
c'est parce qu'il y a des Jeux
Olympiques et qui a l'inquiétude que ça
perturbe celui olympiques mais au-delà
de ce seul sujet des Jeux Olympiques il
y a la question réelle de l'absolu de
l'absolu bêtise et de l'absence de
nécessité d'ouvrir à la concurrence le
transport en Île-de-France merci vous
avez pris six minutes donc pour défendre
plusieurs amendements je vous le concède
alors pas là Monsieur Bazin pour le
4696 je dis quoi je vous donne le micro
merci madame la présidente madame
rapporteur mes chers collègues c'est un
moment en discussion commune mais c'est
pas exactement le même que celui de mon
collègue c'est un sujet que je porte sur
différents articles c'est par rapport à
la date de mise en oeuvre de la réforme
je pense qu'on a un enjeu
d'acceptabilité sociale et que il n'est
pas forcément
judicieux d'impacter des personnes qui
doivent partir cette année ça peut
sembler brutal je pense aussi qu'il y a
un besoin de visibilité
et une retraite ça se prépare d'ailleurs
les dossiers les demandes se font
plusieurs mois à l'avance il y a un
besoin aussi de fiabilité madame le
rapporteur vous avez participé vous avez
mené une audition de du directeur
général de la CNAV il expliquait
d'ailleurs qu'à partir du 1er mars il
n'allait plus répondre aux demandes en
attendant que le droit soit stabilisé
c'est vrai qu'avec le calendrier du
PLFSS rectificatif avec les textes
réglementaires qui qui en découleront
ils vont devoir attendre au moins
jusqu'à mi-mai et on voit bien qu'il y a
quelques mois nécessaires visibilité
fiabilité acceptabilité sociale mais il
y a aussi un autre enjeu celui de la
viabilité financière or le texte en
étant mise en œuvre à partir du 1er
septembre va générer un déficit
supplémentaire de nos comptes de la
Sécurité sociale de 400 millions d'euros
à partir du moment où on ne souhaite pas
aggraver nos comptes publics il semble
préférable de reporter au 1er janvier
prochain la mise en oeuvre de cette
réforme c'est le sens de cet amendement
qui est cohérent avec un certain nombre
d'autres amendements qui modifie le
calendrier de cette réforme